Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a presentation. video or a social media post or a flyer, maybe even a video. To some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestisistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestisistory.com。本期节目由 Adobe Express 赞助，这是一款快速简便、能创作任何内容的应用程序。这是什么意思？嗯，假设你需要做一个演讲或幻灯片、一个视频、一篇社交媒体帖子或一份传单，甚至可能是一个视频。对某些人来说，对我而言肯定也是，这听起来让人望而生畏。但汤姆，有了 Adobe Express 的直观功能，比如模板、生成式 AI 和实时协作，一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express。免费试用。
Search Adobe Express in the App Store. Rava Ruska, a burned-out station building, a sign hanging a skew from the façade, somber silence, the little town all shot up, a deserted track along the edge of a forest, sand, sand, feet, and forest, turkey oak and pine, September mists, the dewy chill of daybreak. The area is devoid of life. Even the birds are in hiding. Suddenly we freeze and stare at each other. Did you hear that? Yes, artillery. Sounds like we're getting near the thick of it. We weren't the only ones to hear. A silent tremor of anxiety ripples through the crowd. That was how it still was then. Later on it would become an everyday thing as much a part of life as a greeting. Then even more. more so. Eventually, the greetings were dropped. The guns took their place. This was how the burning of the world announced itself. So that was the burning of the world by the artist Bella
在 App Store 中搜索 Adobe Express。拉瓦-鲁斯卡（Rava Ruska），一座烧焦的车站大楼，一块歪歪扭扭挂在正面的招牌，死寂般的沉默，这座遭到狂轰滥炸的小镇，森林边缘一条荒废的铁轨，沙子、沙子、双脚和森林，土耳其栎树和松树，九月的薄雾，破晓时分露水的寒意。这个地区毫无生气。连鸟儿都藏了起来。突然，我们僵住了，互相凝视。你听到了吗？是的，炮声。听起来我们正接近激战的中心。听到声音的不止我们。一缕无声的焦虑涟漪般穿过人群。当时情况依然如此。后来这成了家常便饭，就像问候一样，成了生活的一部分。然后甚至更多。甚至更甚。最终，问候被抛弃了。取而代之的是枪炮。这就是世界燃烧宣告自己的方式。所以那是艺术家贝拉
Zomberi Moldovan, who was called up to the Royal Hungarian Honved, which is, of course, in English, defenders of the homeland, in August 1914. And I say, of course, I don't actually speak Hungarian, But fortunately, we are in the presence of someone who does and speaks all the Balkan languages and knows the Eastern Front, like the back of his hand, and that is, of course, Dominic Sandbrook. And he's written one of the most haunting and lyrical of all memoirs, but little known in the English-speaking world because it's about the Eastern Front. And Dominic, I admit, I had never heard of it. But presumably, you know, when you're out in the wilds of Moldova or Belarus or whatever,
·宗贝里-摩尔多瓦（Bella Zomberi Moldovan）眼中的世界燃烧，他在 1914 年 8 月应征加入了皇家匈牙利霍恩维德（Royal Hungarian Honved），当然，用英文来说，就是祖国的保卫者。我这么说，其实我不会说匈牙利语，但幸运的是，我们身边有一位精通匈牙利语、会说所有巴尔干语言并且对东线了如指掌的人，他就是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。他写了一部最令人难忘且极具抒情色彩的回忆录，但在英语世界却鲜为人知，因为它讲述的是东线。多米尼克，我承认，我以前从未听说过它。但据我推测，当你在摩尔多瓦或白俄罗斯等地的荒野中时，
you talk a little else with the circles of Interested. intellectuals and historians. Rugged wily peasants, Tom, surely. Of course you're out there talking with rugged wily peasants, but you're also in the coffee shops, aren't you? Discussing the history of Middle Europa. Well, this book, The Boney of the World, is actually published by the New York Review of Books,
汤姆，你肯定会和志同道合的知识分子和历史学家圈子讨论点别的。粗犷而狡猾的农民，汤姆，肯定是这样。你当然是在那里和粗犷而狡猾的农民交谈，但你也会去咖啡馆，对吧？讨论中欧的历史。嗯，这本书《世界在燃烧》（The Boney of the World）其实是由纽约书评出版社出版的，
I think it is in their classics range. So it's slightly easier to get hold of than you're suggesting. It's a brilliant memoir, actually. It is a really, really haunting book. So this guy, he's on the Adriatic Sea. He's on holiday in the summer of 1914. and then the sort of signs literally go up by the beach by the hotels saying you're called up. You know, all the men are told to report to their regiments and off he goes to the eastern front
我想它在他们的经典丛书系列里。所以它比你暗示的要稍微容易买到一些。这其实是一部极其精彩的回忆录。这是一本真正、真正让人难以忘怀的书。所以这家伙，他在亚得里亚海。1914 年夏天他在度假，然后海滩上、酒店旁几乎立刻挂出了征召入伍的告示。你知道，所有男人都被告知去他们的团报到，然后他就去了东线，
and it's far, far more hellish than he could possibly have imagined. And the funny thing about it is, of course, loads of people listening to this, won't have heard of this, but why would they? Because actually, even though the first shots of the First World War are fired in the east in Bosnia and in Serbia, these places then completely vanish. And Austria basically vanishes from the knowledge of the First World War. War. The Archduke gets shot. There's a few generals with big mustaches in the buildup to the First World War and then it vanishes. The war starts because Austria wants to take revenge on Serbia
那里比他想象的要像地狱得多。有趣的是，当然，听这个节目的很多人都没听说过这个，但他们为什么会知道呢？因为事实上，尽管第一次世界大战的第一枪是在东方的波斯尼亚和塞尔维亚打响的，但这些地方后来完全消失了。而且奥地利基本上从人们对第一次世界大战的认知中消失了。大公被枪杀。在一战爆发前的准备阶段，有几个留着大胡子的将军，然后它就消失了。战争爆发是因为奥地利想向塞尔维亚复仇，
and the Russians want to stop them. And those three countries just then vanish by and large from our own accounts. It's then all Tom is and the Somme and Verdun and stuff. But we're going to put that right because we're going to tell the story this week of what happened in the East. And it's a really, really remarkable story. So first of all, it is completely different from the story of what's going on in the West. In the West, you have the lines of trenches, you have the mud, you have the Tommy's, all of that. It's a stationary war, isn't it? Whereas in the East, it's much more like the Great Northern War, or you might say, like the Eastern Front in the Second World War. It is. The front lines kind of ebbing and flowing, these gigantic armies,
而俄罗斯人想阻止他们。这三个国家随后基本上从我们的记述中消失了。接着全都是汤姆所说的索姆河、凡尔登之类的事情。但我们要纠正这一点，因为我们这周要讲述东方发生的事情。这真是一个非常、非常了不起的故事。所以首先，它与西方发生的事情的故事完全不同。在西方，你有战壕线，你有泥泞，你有汤姆们，所有这一切。这是一场阵地战，对吧？而在东方，它更像大北方战争，或者你可以说，更像是第二次世界大战中的东线。确实如此。前线有点像潮起潮落，这些庞大的军队，
actually without the same technology of the Second World War, so they don't have very good communications. These vast armies kind of completely lost sometimes in kind of forests and marshlands and whatnot. They're wondering about this colossal landscape. And the other important thing about this is this is a war that is fought on the borderlands of three empires. So Austria, Hungary, Russia and Germany. And a lot of the territory that's being fought on is inhabited not by Austrians, Hungarians, Germans or Russians, but by Poles, Ukrainians and Jews, which adds its own kind of flavour to the conflict. Because the borderlands of empires are often bloody. Exactly. And actually, a lot of historians looking at what happened in the Balkans,
实际上没有第二次世界大战那种技术，所以他们的通信非常糟糕。这些庞大的军队有时完全迷失在森林、沼泽等地。他们在广袤的风景中游荡。关于这件事，另一个重要点是，这是一场在三个帝国的边境地区进行的战争。即奥匈帝国、俄罗斯和德国。许多发生战斗的领土居住的不是奥地利人、匈牙利人、德国人或俄罗斯人，而是波兰人、乌克兰人和犹太人，这给冲突增添了它特有的风味。因为帝国的边境地区往往充满血腥。没错。事实上，许多历史学家在审视发生在巴尔干地区、
in East Prussia, and in a place called Galicia, which is now southeastern Poland, and Western Ukraine, they see this as a rehearsal for the horrors to come in the 1930s and 1940s. But let's start with the people who fired the very first shots of the war. So the Austrians, the Serbians. So if you remember, six years ago when we did our series, it seems like six years when we did our first series, the Archduke of Franz Ferdinand was assassinated on 28th of June, 1914 by Gavrilo Prince, in Sarajevo, with the collaboration of elements of Serbian military intelligence. And then for the next four weeks, the Austrians weighed up their options, and they decided this was their chance to settle accounts with Serbia forever. And to remind
东普鲁士，以及一个叫做加利西亚（Galicia，现为波兰东南部和乌克兰西部）的地方的事情时，将这视为对 20 世纪 30 年代和 40 年代即将发生的恐怖的彩排。但让我们从打响战争第一枪的人开始。也就是奥地利人、塞尔维亚人。所以如果你还记得，六年前当我们做我们的系列节目时，感觉就像六年前我们做第一个系列节目时一样，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公于 1914 年 6 月 28 日在萨拉热窝被加夫里洛·普林西普（Gavrilo Prince）暗杀，塞尔维亚军事情报部门的某些分子参与其中。然后在接下来的四周里，奥地利人权衡了他们的选择，他们决定这是彻底清算塞尔维亚的机会。为了提醒
people about the Austro-Hungarian Empire, it's a dual monarchy under the 170-year-old Franz Joseph. So in other words, what you have is Austrians, Hungarians ruling this huge variety of people, so Czechs, Poles, Ukrainians, Croats, some Italians, lots of Romanians, and so on and so forth. At the time, it was seen as a bit of a sick man of Europe. I think The trend among historians now is to say, actually, the empire is still kind of staggering along. It's not necessarily about to collapse. In the series we did on the assassination of the Archduke and then the Road to the First World War, I mean, you very convincingly represented the Austro-Hungarian Empire as not a basket case.
人们注意奥匈帝国，这是一个在 170 岁高龄的弗朗茨·约瑟夫统治下的二元君主国。换句话说，你拥有的是统治着这个庞大而多样化群体的奥地利人、匈牙利人，比如捷克人、波兰人、乌克兰人、克罗地亚人、一些意大利人、许多罗马尼亚人，等等。当时，它被视为欧洲的病夫。我认为现在历史学家的趋势是说，实际上，这个帝国仍然在踉跄前行。它不一定即将崩溃。在我们制作的关于大公遇刺以及随后通往第一次世界大战之路的系列节目中，我的意思是，你非常令人信服地将奥匈帝国描述为一个并非烂摊子的国家。
But I have to say, in a spoiler alert, the record of the Austro-Hungarian army in the campaigns to come. I mean, they're a shower. Yeah, they're an absolute shambles, Tom. I don't think that's going too far. I think if you're looking for an object lesson in utter ineptitude and incompetence, but in a kind of a pleasing way, no? Because, I mean, the thing about the Austrians
但我必须说，剧透一下，奥匈帝国军队在接下来战役中的表现。我的意思是，他们简直是一团糟。是的，他们绝对是一团糟，汤姆。我认为这么说并不过分。如果你想寻找一个关于彻底无能和愚蠢的客观教训，但又以一种令人愉快的方式，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，奥地利人的特点是，
is you imagine them being slightly inept while eating loads of cake and listening to Mozart and thinking about Freud and Schoenberg and stuff. You'd be disappointed if they then ended up being ruthlessly efficient, wouldn't you? Well, I mean, it was a counterpoint to your Austro-Hungarian propaganda
你想象他们一边吃着大量蛋糕，听着莫扎特，思考着弗洛伊德和勋伯格之类的事情，一边有点无能。如果他们最终变得冷酷无情地高效，你会感到失望的，不是吗？好吧，我的意思是，这是对你在前两个系列中
in the previous two series. I was reading Max Hastings' catastrophe And he said about the Austro-Hungarian army, its principal strength lay in exotic parade uniforms and splendid bands. And I'm not taking that as a criticism. No, no, no, no, that's we admire that, surely. The big fear for people in the Austro-Hungarian elite is nationalism, is ethnic nationalism,
对奥匈帝国的宣传的一种反衬。我当时在读马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）的《灾难》（Catastrophe），他谈到奥匈帝国军队时说，它的主要实力在于奇异的阅兵制服和灿烂的军乐队。我不认为这是一种批评。不，不，不，不，我们钦佩这一点，对吧？奥匈帝国精英们最大的恐惧是民族主义，是民族主义，
and in particular the South Slav ambitions of the Kingdom of Serbia. And the person who really ends up directing the war effort, and the key character in today's story is a man called Baron Franz, Conrad von Hutzendorf. So Conrad von Hertzendorf. He's 61 years old. He's the chief of the general staff. He's got this sort of strange brush of hair and he's got, of course, a gigantic moustache. Is there anyone in this story coming up who doesn't have a gigantic mustache? And they just get bigger. Yeah. I was having to take out the pheasuras running out of superlatives.
特别是塞尔维亚王国的南斯拉夫主义野心。真正最终指导战争努力的人，也是今天故事中的关键人物，是一个名叫弗朗茨·康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫（Franz, Conrad von Hutzendorf）男爵的人。也就是康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫。他 61 岁。他是总参谋长。他有着那种奇怪的刷子般的头发，当然，他还留着一把巨大的胡子。这个故事里接下来的任何人没有巨大的胡子吗？而且它们只会越来越大。是的。我不得不拿走那些用尽最高级的词汇的短语。
Massive, gigantic, colossal, stupendous, stupefying. Each time you think you've seen the biggest moustache, you're wrong because there's another one to come. Yeah. So basically, the further east you go in the story, I think the moustaches get bigger. And this guy, Conrad, the salient thing about him is he's in love with a much younger woman and he wants to impress her by basically starting a world war. Correct. That's my vague memory of him.
庞大、巨大、宏伟、惊人、匪夷所思。每次你以为你看到了最大的胡子，你都错了，因为还有一个更大的要来。是的。所以基本上，在这个故事里你越往东走，我想胡子就越大。而这个人，康拉德，关于他最显着的一点是，他爱上了一个年轻得多的女人，他想通过发动一场世界大战来给她留下深刻印象。没错。这就是我对他的模糊记忆。
Yeah. So we talked about this a tiny bit in the Franz Ferdinand series. Conrad, he's a very dapper man and he's sort of, like all these people, he's kind of melancholic. But he's got a romantic side. So when his first wife died, I think right about 1907, he met this woman at a dinner party. She was called Gina von Rininghouse. She was 27, and she was the wife of an Austrian businessman. And Conrad immediately said to himself, well, this is the lady for me.
是的。所以在弗朗茨·斐迪南系列中，我们稍微谈过这一点。康拉德是一个非常衣冠楚楚的人，他有点像所有人一样，有点忧郁。但他有浪漫的一面。所以当他的第一任妻子去世时，我想大约在 1907 年，他在一次晚宴上遇到了这个女人。她叫吉娜·冯·里宁豪斯（Gina von Rininghouse）。她 27 岁，是一个奥地利商人的妻子。康拉德立刻对自己说，好吧，这就是我要找的女士。
And he then wrote her 3,000 letters. When he could have been looking at railway timetables. Right. Oh, I'll write another letter instead. He wrote her 3,000 letters begging her. So, you know, I enjoyed meeting at the dinner party. Would you consider leaving your husband and marrying me? And amazingly, she ends up having an affair with him.
然后他给她写了 3,000 封信。本可以去看铁路时刻表的。对。哦，我还是写另一封信吧。他给她写了 3,000 封信乞求她。所以，你知道，我很享受在晚宴上的相遇。你会考虑离开你丈夫嫁给我吗？令人惊奇的是，她最后和他有了一段婚外情，
but to get a divorce and then to remarry, they will need effectively the permission of the emperor and the approval of Viennese High Society. And Conrad knows the only way to get that is by starting and winning a world war. And so that's what he does. Well, although, to be fair to him, he has always been deadly serious
但要离婚然后重新结婚，他们实际上需要皇帝的准许和维也纳上流社会的批准。康拉德知道获得这一许可的唯一方法就是挑起并赢得一场世界大战。所以他就是这么做的。好吧，尽管对她公平地说，他一直对塞尔维亚的威胁
about the threat of Serbia. He really does see Serbia as a lethal menace to the empire's survival. So he's the kind of hawk, isn't he, to Franz Ferdinand's dove? Completely he is. So in 1913, he had asked 25 times if he could start a war with Serbia.
抱有极其认真的态度。他确实将塞尔维亚视为帝国生存的致命威胁。所以他是那种鹰派，对吧，与弗朗茨·斐迪南的鸽派相对？完全是这样。所以在 1913 年，他曾 25 次请求发动对塞尔维亚的战争。
And basically, Franz Ferdinand had blocked him at every opportunity. But within hours of Franz Ferdinand's death, he says, brilliant, this is the opportunity. What an irony. The one guy who was stopping me, I can use his death as the pretext. And he said to the Foreign Minister of Austria, Count Berchttold, you know, we have a poisonous adder at our heel and we need to stamp on its head. And Berchtold, I think we quoted this in the Franz Ferdinand series, later wrote, with a faraway look of melancholy on his fine, featured face, he concluded emphatically with three words,
基本上，弗朗茨·斐迪南在每个机会都阻挠了他。但在弗朗茨·斐迪南死后的几个小时内，他说，太棒了，这就是机会。多么大的讽刺啊。唯一阻止我的人，我可以利用他的死作为借口。他对奥地利外交大臣贝希托尔德伯爵（Count Berchtold）说，你知道，我们的脚后跟有一条毒蛇，我们需要踩扁它的头。贝希托尔德，我想我们在弗朗茨·斐迪南系列中引用过这句话，后来写道，他那面部线条优美的脸上带着一种遥远的忧郁神情，坚定地以三个词作了结，
war, war, war. So there's never been any conspiracy theory that he was behind the murder of Franz Ferdin. Gosh, that's a good idea. It's a good one, isn't it? Well, maybe that could be the conspiracy that our team of crack detectives will be interested in the second and half of the show. They can investigate that.
战争，战争，战争。所以从来没有阴谋论说他是弗朗茨·斐迪南谋杀案的幕后黑手。天哪，这是个好主意。这是个好主意，不是吗？好吧，也许这可以成为我们那支精锐侦探团队在节目后半部分会感兴趣的阴谋。他们可以调查这个。
That's the season finale, surely. That is exciting news for listeners. What's coming in the second half? You'll be surprised. Well, you won't have you've heard the previous episode, but newcomers will be surprised. Right. So the Austrians send their ultimatum on 23rd of July. The Serbs rejects the key demands.
这肯定是季终集。这对听众来说是个令人兴奋的消息。后半部分会有什么？你会大吃一惊的。好吧，如果你没听过前一集你可能不会，但新听众会大吃一惊的。好。所以奥地利人在 7 月 23 日发出了他们的最后通牒。塞尔维亚人拒绝了核心要求。
And on the 28th of July, Franz Joseph signs the Declaration of War. Now, the mad thing about the Austrians is they are conscious that the Serbs have this gigantic patron and protector in Russia. But they really give Russia no thought at all. They don't send any troops to their eastern border. Conrad's hope is that basically the Germans will either deter the Russians or in the worst case scenario, if the Russians join the war, the Germans will deal with them. All he's thinking about is the spectacular victory that he's going to win over Serbia. The question, though, of course, is Austria going to get a win?
7 月 28 日，弗朗茨·约瑟夫签署了宣战声明。现在，奥地利人疯狂的地方在于，他们意识到塞尔维亚人在俄罗斯有一个庞大的靠山和保护者。但他们根本没有把俄罗斯放在眼里。他们没有向东部边境派遣任何军队。康拉德的希望是，基本上德国人要么威慑俄罗斯人，要么在最坏的情况下，如果俄罗斯人参战，德国人会处理他们。他脑子里想的全是他在塞尔维亚将要取得的辉煌胜利。不过，问题当然是奥地利能否取得胜利？
I mean, this is the weird thing. The Austrians haven't really given any thought whether they actually win such a war. So they have 40 infantry divisions, the Austrians. The Serbs have 11. The Serbs population is much smaller. Oddly, relative to the population, the Serbs have more troops, but the Austrians have more in an absolute numbers. The Austrians have quite good weapons, but not enough of them.
我的意思是，这就是奇怪的地方。奥地利人根本没有考虑过他们是否真的能赢得这样一场战争。所以他们有 40 个步兵师，奥地利人。塞尔维亚人有 11 个。塞尔维亚人口要少得多。奇怪的是，相对于人口而言，塞尔维亚人有更多的军队，但奥地利人在绝对数量上更多。奥地利人有相当好的武器，但数量不够。
And the reason they don't have enough of them is because before the war, there'd been this endless, endless budget squabbling with the Hungarian parliament. And that, I think, tells its own story about Austria-Hungary's greatest military problem, which is basically diversity is not its strength. So most of the men don't even speak the same language. most of the officers speak German and there's actually been huge arguments about whether that should continue or not. You know, is it right
他们武器不够的原因是，在战争爆发前，他们与匈牙利议会进行了无休无止的预算争吵。我认为，这说明了奥匈帝国最大的军事问题，那就是多样性并不是它的力量。所以大多数人甚至不会说同一种语言。大多数军官说德语，而关于这种情况是否应该继续下去，实际上曾有过巨大的争论。你知道，这正确吗？
that all officers have to speak German? But out of every hundred soldiers in the Austro-Hungarian army, 26 speak German, 23 Hungarian, 13 Czech, 9, Serbian or Croat, 8 speak Polish, 8 are Ukrainians, 7 in Romania, 4 are Slovak's and 2 are Syvenians. And I'm sure there's also a Cateria that says other.
所有的军官都必须说德语？但在奥匈帝国军队的每一百名士兵中，26 人说德语，23 人说匈牙利语，13 人说捷克语，9 人说塞尔维亚语或克罗地亚语，8 人说波兰语，8 人是乌克兰人，7 人说罗马尼亚语，4 人是斯洛伐克人，2 人是斯洛文尼亚人。我确信还有一个标明“其他”的类别。
Roma. Yeah, exactly. Or Jews who speak Yiddish or something. Yeah. So, in other words, you know, this is a sort of a real ragbag, kind of, it's a tower of Babel, Tom. It's a travelling Tower of Babel. Conrad thinks, well, that's not a problem. We can overcome this. He had written many times before the war. In 1890, for example, he had written that leadership is all about swift decision-making and strength of will.
罗姆人。是的，正好。或者说意第绪语的犹太人之类的。是的。所以，换句话说，你知道，这是一群真正的杂牌军，这是一个巴别塔，汤姆。这是一个行走的巴别塔。康拉德认为，好吧，这不是问题。我们可以克服这一点。他在战前曾多次写过。例如，在 1890 年，他曾写道，领导力全在于迅速的决策和坚强的意志。
All you need is strength of will. I mean, actually, the Austrians don't really have either of those things? They're incredibly slow decision-makers. And as I remember, they also have a massively complicated railway system. prevents them from moving troops rapidly across their territories. Yes, exactly. Which is what Conrad should have been studying rather than writing letters to Gina, one might argue. Well, every way in which they organise this war is laughable.
你只需要坚强的意志。我的意思是，实际上，奥地利人这两样东西都没有？他们是极其缓慢的决策者。而且我记得，他们还有一个极其复杂的铁路系统。这阻碍了他们在领土上迅速调动军队。是的，正是如此。人们可能会认为，康拉德应该研究这个，而不是给吉娜写信。好吧，他们组织这场战争的方方面面都荒谬可笑。
Here's a perfect example, right? The morning after the Declaration War, the early hours of the 29th of July, they say, well, we're going to kick off the campaign. They have this river warship called the Bodrog. Great name. Which begins firing shells across the Danube into the centre of Belgrade. So you think, okay, right, it's all going to kick off. But then the Austrians do absolutely nothing.
这里有一个完美的例子，对吧？宣战的第二天早上，即 7 月 29 日的清晨，他们说，好吧，我们要打响战役了。他们有一艘名为博德罗格（Bodrog）的内河军舰。好名字。开始向多瑙河发射炮弹，打进贝尔格莱德市中心。所以你想，好吧，对，要大干一场了。但随后奥地利人什么也没做。
So they then do nothing for two weeks. And the reason for that is that Conrad to please the kind of farming lobby in the empire had introduced harvest leave for the army. So all his men are away, like literally working in the sort of Thomas Hardy. Yeah. With their sithes. Yeah, and like it's Thomas Hardy novel. They're kind of sithing corn or wheat or whatever they're doing.
于是他们随后两个星期什么都没做。原因是康拉德为了取悦帝国境内的农业游说团，为军队引入了收获假。所以他所有的士兵都不在，简直就像是在托马斯·哈迪（Thomas Hardy）的小说里一样。是的。拿着镰刀。是的，就像托马斯·哈迪的小说一样。他们有点在割玉米或小麦，或者做他们正在做的事情。
And the troops from places like Zagreb and Budapest won't get back until the end of July. So basically, the Serbs have all this time to get organized. They've got two weeks to get organized. And here is the maddest part of this story. The man that the Serbs want to lead their armies, lead the resistance. It's a man called Radimir Putnik. And he had led their armies in the Balkan wars. So the wars they'd fought against the Ottoman Empire and then Bulgaria just before the First World War.
来自萨格勒布和布达佩斯等地的部队直到 7 月底才回来。所以基本上，塞尔维亚人有充足的时间来组织自己。他们有两个星期的时间来组织。而这个故事最疯狂的部分来了。塞尔维亚人想要领导他们的军队、领导抵抗的人。是一个名叫拉多米尔·普特尼克（Radimir Putnik）的人。他在巴尔干战争中领导过他们的军队。也就是他们在第一次世界大战前不久对奥斯曼帝国然后是保加利亚进行的战争。
And Radimir Putnik, everybody loves Radimir Putnik in Serbia. He's in his late 60s. He's got a huge white beard. Of course. And he's got chronic emphysema. Of course. So he's basically, he's a peak First World War General. He is.
拉多米尔·普特尼克，每个人在塞尔维亚都爱拉多米尔·普特尼克。他六十多岁。他有着巨大的白胡子。当然。而且他有慢性肺气肿。当然。所以他基本上是巅峰时期的第一次世界大战将军。他确实是。
Well, also he's been smoking those kind of really aqua, heavy, balkan cigarettes. The kind of you love when you're hanging out in the cafes of Bucharest. Now, here's the thing, right? Where has he been? Of course, he's been taking the waters at a spa while this has been going on, and in all places, in the Austro-Hungarian Empire. So this bloke Putnik has been at a spa called Bad Glykenberg, which is in Bohemia.
好吧，他还一直在抽那些非常浓烈、沉重的巴尔干香烟。你在布加勒斯特的咖啡馆里闲逛时最喜欢的那种。现在，事情是这样的，对吧？他在哪里？当然，这一切发生时，他一直在一个温泉疗养地泡温泉，而且在所有地方中，偏偏是在奥匈帝国境内。所以这个叫普特尼克的家伙一直在一个叫做巴德格利肯贝格（Bad Glykenberg）的温泉，它在波希米亚。
He finds out there's going to be a war. He says, oh, I better get home. He gets on the train, and he's literally changing trains in Budapest when he's arrested by the Austro-Hungarians. And this, I think, is the ultimate sign of the Austro-Hungarian lack of seriousness. They've arrested this guy who's going to lead Serbia's armies against them. And when Franz Joseph hears about this, he says, oh, this is very poor form. You can't arrest this guy.
他发现要打仗了。他说，哦，我最好回家。他上了火车，正字面意义上在布达佩斯换乘火车时被奥匈帝国人逮捕了。我认为，这是奥匈帝国缺乏严肃性的终极标志。他们逮捕了这个将要领导塞尔维亚军队对抗他们的家伙。当弗朗茨·约瑟夫听到这个消息时，他说，哦，这太不像话了。你不能逮捕这家伙。
Let him go home. It's chivalrous. Yeah. So do you know what they do? They literally put him on a train to go home. Now, it takes him an eternity to actually get home. I mean, on one level, it reflects tremendously well on the Austro-Hungarian Empire. Yeah.
让他回家吧。这很有骑士风度。是的。你知道他们做了什么吗？他们 literalmente（字面意义上）把他塞上一辆火车让他回家。现在，他花了好长时间才真正回到家。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，这极大地反映了奥匈帝国的良好品德。是的。
On another level, what were they thinking? I don't think the British would have done that with Napoleon. Do you? Well, would they have done that with Michael Collins? No, I don't think they would. Although they did, no, because they did arrest Eamon de Valera and then let him go. Then he locked him up in Lincoln jail. Yeah, but later on, they arrested him by accident and let him go when the truth was going on,
从另一方面来说，他们在想什么？我不认为英国人会对拿破仑这么做。你觉得呢？好吧，他们会对迈克尔·柯林斯（Michael Collins）这么做吗？不，我想他们不会。尽管他们确实，不，因为他们确实逮捕了埃蒙·德瓦莱拉（Eamon de Valera）然后放了他。然后把他关在林肯监狱里。是的，但后来，他们在停战谈判进行时，不小心逮捕了他又放了他。哦，好吧，如果是停战协议，那还算合理。又是一个赞美我们敬爱的国家的好机会，汤姆。太棒了。干得漂亮。你处理得太完美了。无论如何，普特尼克花了很长时间才回到家。其他塞尔维亚军官基本上不得不炸开他的保险箱来找出他的计划。
all the truce negotiations. Oh, well, that's fair enough, if it's a truth. Yet another opportunity to praise our beloved country, Tom. Wonderful. Well done. You handled that beautifully. Anyway, putting it takes some ages to get home. The other Serbian officers basically have to blow open his safe to find out what his plans are.
他们读了他的计划。他的计划是，我们不会在边境与奥地利人交战。我们实际上将从贝尔格莱德撤退，等待奥地利人行动后再做出反应。所以，在纸面上，塞尔维亚人在这场战争中是巨大的劣势方。我的意思是，这就是战争，第一次世界大战就是关于这个的，而没有人真正了解它。塞尔维亚人大约有 20 万人，但他们刚刚打过巴尔干战争，那是非常残酷的战争，实际上他们在其中不一定能保持道德上的光彩。他们实际上
They read his plans. His plans are we won't engage the Austrians on the border. We'll actually withdraw from Belgrade and we'll wait for the Austrians to move before reacting. So the Serbs are on paper, massive underdogs in this war. I mean, this is the war. the First World War is all about, and nobody really knows anything about it. The Serbs have about 200,000 men, but they've just fought in the Balkan wars, very vicious wars, actually, in which they didn't necessarily cover themselves with certainly not moral glory. They haven't really
没有留下任何制服。每个人都说他们看起来像流浪者和稻草人。他们看起来饱经沧桑，但塞尔维亚士兵以坚忍闻名。他们能融入山中，对吧？他们能融入山中。所以刚写了一本关于东线的杰出新书的历史学家尼克·劳埃德（Nick Lloyd）。他引用了一个人的话。那个人说，如果你给塞尔维亚士兵一块面包和一个洋葱，他就心满意足了。你的经验是这样的吗？你会赞同这一点吗？是的，我想是的。我认为这绝对正确。我的意思是，以我的经验来看，比如，他们总是吃洋葱之类的事物。他们很喜欢。他们也非常
got any uniforms left. Everyone says they look like tramps and scarecrows. They're sort of very battered looking, but they're famously stoical, the Serbian soldiers. And they can melt into the mountains, can't they? They can melt into the mountains. So the historian, Nick Lloyd, who's just written a brilliant book on the Eastern Front. He quotes one guy. guy who said, if you give the Serbian soldier bread and an onion, he's satisfied. And is that your experience? Would you concur with that? Yeah, I think so. I think that's absolutely right. I mean, in my experience, like, they were always eating onions and stuff. They love it. They're also, they're very
凶猛。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的，这现在正在退化为绝对的巴尔干刻板印象 101，但是，是的。迈克尔·帕林（Michael Palin）式的。是的，完全如此。塞尔维亚人是一个骄傲、粗犷的民族。基本上，你只要跟塞尔维亚人打仗，他们就是彻头彻尾的混蛋。他们把战斗视为一场伟大的冒险。风笛手在演奏，小提琴在拉着民歌，伴随着这些音乐，他们被引领投入战斗。实际上，这是塞尔维亚历史的一种延续，因为在 20 世纪 90 年代，当他们在后南斯拉夫战争中作战时，音乐是塞尔维亚民族主义的巨大组成部分，有一种叫做“涡轮民谣”（Turbofolk）的东西，那是震撼人心的音乐。你能来做这个真是太棒了。
fierce. I mean, this is a terrible, this is now degenerating to absolute sort of bulken stereotype 101, but, yeah. The Michael Palin of. Yeah, exactly. The Serbs are a proud, rugged people. Basically, you're just fine. fighting the Serbs, they're complete bastards. They see fighting as a great adventure. They're led into battle by these musicians playing on bagpipes and playing like folk songs on fiddles. And actually, this is a continuity in Serbian history because in the 1990s, when they were fighting in the post-Eugoslav wars, music was a huge part of Serbian nationalism, something called Turbofolk, pounding music. It's brilliant you're here to do this.
哦，那太好了。好吧，带来了你所有的本地知识。好吧，是的，我在报纸上读到的。无论如何，回到奥地利人这里。奥地利人期待着一场彻底的轻松胜利。基本上，康拉德想要一场真正快速的胜利，因为如果他对塞尔维亚取得快速胜利，他认为罗马尼亚和保加利亚会加入同盟国一方。
Oh, that's great. Well, bringing all your local knowledge. Okay. Well, yeah, I read that in the newspaper. Anyway, back to the Austrians. The Austrians are expecting a complete walkover. And basically, Conrad wants a really quick victory because if he wins a quick victory over Serbia, he thinks Romania and Bulgaria will pile in on the side of the central powers.
然而，此时，康拉德承认，实际上他将不得不去领导军队对抗俄国人。他不能再假装俄国人不存在了。于是他在周围物色对抗塞尔维亚人的理想人选。一个人的名字跳进了他的脑海，他的夏天可能有一个不幸的开始，因为他是波斯尼亚总督。
However, at this point, Conrad accepts that actually he will have to go and lead the army against the Russians. He can't pretend the Russians don't exist any longer. So he casts round for the ideal man to fight the Serbs. And a man pops into his head who's had a perhaps unfortunate beginning to the summer because this is the governor of Bosnia.
他叫奥斯卡·波蒂奥雷克（Oscar Pottyurek）将军。他就是那个邀请弗朗茨·斐迪南去萨拉热窝、对他的安全负有责任、曾告诉他绝对不会出任何问题的人。如果你还记得的话，甚至曾告诉他的军队在任何情况下都不要进入萨拉热窝，因为他想向世界展示这对弗朗茨·斐迪南来说有多安全。但除了暗杀之外，我的意思是，进展得很顺利。
He's called General Oscar Pottyurek. He is the man who had invited Franz Ferdinand to Sarajevo, being responsible for his security, had told him nothing could possibly go wrong. And if you remember, had even told his army not to enter Sarajevo under any circumstances because he wanted to show the world how safe it was for Franz Ferdinand. But aside from the assassination, I mean, it had gone well.
除此之外，这其实是一次极其出色的旅行。进展得非常顺利。现在，波蒂奥雷克有要证明自己的地方，他写信给维也纳，他说，我打算采取绝对的进攻态势，这就是我们在本节目中采用的座右铭，对吧，汤姆？是的，确实如此。不过，你提到了马克斯·黑斯廷斯的书《灾难》。波蒂奥雷克其实从未打过仗，马克斯·黑斯廷斯将他描述为，我引用：
It had actually been a brilliant trip otherwise. It's gone really well. Now, Poitioic has a point to prove, and he wrote to Vienna, he said, I intend to be absolutely offensive, which is the mantra that we adopt on this show, isn't it, Tom? Yes, it is. However, you mentioned Max Hastings's book, Catastrophe. Pottyorik has never actually fought in a battle, and Max Hastings describes him as, and I quote,
一个单身汉，他将一生像修道士一样奉献给了他的职业，同时对其中任何现代或重要的方面一无所知。所以，也许并不是很有希望。8 月 12 日，也就是奥地利人宣战两周后，这太疯狂了，波蒂奥雷克终于说，好吧，我们准备好了。他下令第 5 军从东波斯尼亚渡过德里纳河（Drina）挺进中塞尔维亚，这里山峦起伏，森林非常非常茂密。所以非常适合军事机动。这简直是一团糟。所以在第一天，架桥设备没有出现。基本上，他们不得不派工兵划过去建造这些浮桥。
a bachelor who had devoted his life monastically to his profession, while remaining ignorant of every aspect of it that was either. modern or important. So, maybe not very promising. On the 12th of August, so two weeks after the Austrians had declared war, which is mad, Pottyurek finally says, right, we're ready. And he orders the 5th Army to advance across the river Drina from eastern Bosnia into central Serbia, which is mountainous and very, very densely forested. So excellent for military maneuvering. It's a total shambles. So on the first day, the bridging equipment doesn't turn up. So basically, they have to send their engineers to paddle across and build these pontoon bridges.
他们都过去了。那是八月的巴尔干。热得难以置信。尘土飞扬得难以置信。他们背着巨大的背包，汗流浃背。马克斯·黑斯廷斯引用了一个名叫马蒂安·马拉西奇（Mattie and Malasich）的士兵的话。他说，口渴，口渴，口渴。我们的装备重如铅，酷热难耐。
They all get across. It's the Balkans in August. It's incredibly hot. It's incredibly dusty. They're carrying these huge packs and they're dripping with sweat. Max Hastings quotes a soldier called Mattie and Malasich. He said, thirsty, thirsty, thirsty. Our kit as heavy as lead, unbearable heat.
然而我们必须继续前进，继续前进。太艰难了，以至于一个人会本能地问自己，他为什么被带到这个世界上。难道只是为了受苦吗？所以士气很好。士气并不是绝佳的。他们在闷热和像尘土一样的环境中穿过所有这些塞尔维亚村庄行军。但他们有点惊扰地发现这个地方几乎是空的。所以很安静，太安静了。
And yet we must keep going, keep going. It's so hard that a man instinctively asks himself why he was brought into the world. Was it just to suffer? So morale is good. Morale is not tip-top. They march in suffocating heat and, like, dust through all these Serbian villages. But they're slightly perturbed to see the place is almost empty. So it's silent, too silent.
非常好，汤姆。非常好。只有老太婆和小孩子。咯咯笑着。他们有白眼球吗？毫无疑问。但没有男人。男人们在哪里？
Very good, Tom. Very good. There are just our old crones and small children. Cackling. Do they have white eyeballs? Undoubtedly. But there's no men. Where are the men?
我们在关于比利时的那一集里谈到了德国人对法兰克-蒂尔厄尔（Franc de Ruhrers）即游击队的恐惧。但这处于不同的水平，因为塞尔维亚人，他们热爱。我的意思是，塞尔维亚人热爱游击队。所以从一开始，他们就发动了这场游击战。奥地利人脑海中的这种印象被以下事实加剧了：塞尔维亚人，甚至是他们的正规部队，因为他们没有留下任何制服，看起来就像强盗。他们有点，你知道，身上挂着弹药带。我的意思是，基本上，他们就是强盗。是的，差不多。
We talked in the episode about Belgium about the Germans fear of Franc de Ruhrers of sort of partisans. But this is on a different level because the service, they love a. I mean, the Serbs love a partisan. And so from the very beginning, they waged this partisan campaign. And it's exacerbated in the minds of the Austrians by the fact that the Serbs, even their regular troops, because they don't have any uniforms left, they look like bandits. They've kind of got their, you know, sort of bandoliers of ammunition. I mean, basically, they are bandits. Yeah, pretty much.
所以他们会做的是，奥地利人穿过一个村庄，然后他们穿过去，走进树林里。此时，塞尔维亚人就会出击。他们从后面向所有人开枪，然后融入巴尔干的风景中。现在，奥地利人可不会逆来顺受。现在我们来到了东线的一个巨大特征，无论它在哪里发生，其实都一样。这就是对平民的杀戮。奥地利人在比利时让德国人看起来像，你知道，社会工作者之类的人。对吧。
So what they will do is the Austrians will march through a village, and then they'll go through and they'll go off into the woods. And at this point, the Serbs will strike. They'll shoot them all from behind, and they'll melt away into the Balkan landscape. Now, the Austrians do not take this lying down. And now we come to a massive feature of the Eastern Front, no matter where it happens, actually. And this is the killing of civilians. The Austrians make the Germans in Belgium look like, you know, social workers or something. Right.
所以他们的战地指挥官是一个名叫利博里乌斯·里特·冯·弗兰克（Liborius, Ritter von Frank）将军的家伙。他当然是。他说，听着，塞尔维亚人无论如何都是糟糕透顶的人。既然我们受到平民的攻击，那我们就撕破脸皮了，忘掉国际法吧，它真的不适用。让我们直接，你知道，大开杀戒吧。所以他们立刻开始掠夺和焚烧这些村庄。他们射杀任何他们甚至有一点点认为与游击活动有关的人。现在，我必须说，在任何人开始为塞尔维亚人哭泣之前，
So their field commander is a guy called General Liborius, Ritter von Frank. Of course he is. And he says, listen, the Serbs are terrible people anyway. Since we're under attack from civilians, like the gloves are off, forget about international law, doesn't really apply. Let's just, you know, go for it. So straight away they start looting and burning these villages. They shoot anybody that they think even remotely is connected with partisan activity. Now, I have to say, before anyone starts sort of weeping for the Serbs,
塞尔维亚人在三年前的巴尔干战争中确实让自己名誉扫地。我的意思是，他们在科索沃、马其顿等地表现得确实极其恶劣。他们种下了什么，现在就在一定程度上收获什么。我能问一下，在比利时，当德国人对平民犯下暴行时，这显然对德国的声誉是个坏消息，因此从长远来看对他们进行战争的能力也是个坏消息。但有人在关注巴尔干地区发生的事情吗？伦敦绅士俱乐部里是不是有一种轻描淡写的态度，认为这只是巴尔干地区人们常做的那种事？完全正确。
the Serbs three years earlier had really disgraced themselves in the Balkan Wars. I mean, they had behaved really atrociously in Kosovo and Macedonia and so on. What they've sowed, they are now reaping to some extent. Can I just ask, in Belgium, when the Germans commit atrocities against civilian, This is obviously bad news for Germany's reputation and therefore in the long run for their ability to prosecute the war. But is anyone paying attention to what's going on in the Balkans? And isn't there a kind of a slight attitude in the gentlemen's clubs of London that this is just the kind of thing that people do in the Balkans? Yeah, totally right.
双重标准。同样的双重标准也适用于我们谈论俄国人在波兰和乌克兰的暴行时，例如。我的意思是，完全如此。基本上西方没有人关心。而且就他们在乎的程度而言，每当提起时，他们都会说，好吧，我的意思是，这种事情在那里一直都在发生。古老的仇恨。古老的仇恨，完全如此。
Double standard. The same double standard applies when we're talking about the Russian atrocities in Poland and Ukraine, for example. I mean, exactly that. that basically nobody cares in the West. And insofar as they do care, whenever it comes up, they say, well, I mean, this kind of thing happens there all the time. Ancient hatreds. Agent hatreds, exactly.
事情就是这样。而且，尽管说了“塞尔维亚人种下了什么，现在就在收获什么”，即便如此，还是有一些非常、非常残酷的故事。这里有一个很好的例子。由奥地利人自己讲述。这是一个年轻的匈牙利军官亚历山大·帕拉瓦奇尼（Alexander Palavaccini）讲述的。8 月 17 日，他的部队纵队遭到来自玉米地的射击。他们派出了巡逻队，
That's exactly what happens. And having said, oh, what the Serbs sowed there now reaping, even so, there are some really, really grim stories. So here's a good example. It's a told by the Austrians themselves. So this is from a young Hungarian officer called Alexander Palavaccini. So his column of troops was fired on from a cornfield on the 17th of August. And they sent out patrols.
这些巡逻队带回了 63 个人。他们说在田野附近发现了这些人。帕拉瓦奇尼声称，其中一些是被捕获的带有步枪的妇女和儿童。其中一人是一名被捕获带有手榴弹的正教会神父。他写道：一小时后，只能看到一个万人坑。为了不让我们的士兵听到枪声而感到不安，
and these patrols came back with 63 people. They said they'd found hanging around the field. Some of these, Palavacchina claimed, were women and children caught with rifles. One of them was an Orthodox priest caught with grenades. And he wrote, An hour later, only a mass grave was visible. In order not to upset our soldiers by the sound of shooting,
这些人被刺刀刺死。据说那个神父的胡子被扯掉了。在经历了对他们的暴行之后，我们的人是如此愤怒。他非常严厉地描述了这一点，他没有任何后悔或内疚。他说，对我们的仇恨是无边无际的，每个人都是我们的敌人。我们不是在与一支 30 万人的军队作战，而是在与整个国家作战。多米尼克，据推测，神父拥有手榴弹、妇女和儿童拥有枪支的证据完全来自于开枪射杀他们的人。
these people were bayoneted to death. The priest's beard had supposedly been ripped off. Our men were that angry after the atrocities committed against them. He describes this very starkly, he has no regrets or guilt. He says, the hatred for us is boundless and everyone is our enemy. We're not fighting against an army of 300,000, but against a whole nation. And Dominic, presumably, the evidence for the priest having the grenades and the women and children having guns comes exclusively from the people who've shot them.
当然，是的。谁能说这有多真实呢？而且奥地利人根本不试图掩盖这一点。他们实际上希望它是公开的。所以康拉德说，你知道，把这做得非常明显，因为我们想恐吓人们与我们合作。一周后的 8 月 24 日，另一位奥地利-匈牙利军官讲述了一个可怕的故事。他说，我遇到了一纵队 30 个人集合起来准备处决。他说他们站在那里时被踢、被鞭打之类的。
Of course, yes. Who's to say how true this is? And the Austrians do not try to cover this up at all. They actually want it to be public. So Conrad says, you know, make this very overt because we want to terrify people into collaborating with us. There's a terrible story told by another Austro-Hungarian officer a week later, the 24th of August. He says, I met a column of 30 people assembled for execution. He says they were being kind of kicked and whipped and whatnot while they were standing there.
他和另外几个人试图制止这样做的人，但不可能。他接着说，修道院后面的树林边缘有一个刑场。塞尔维亚人不得不自己挖坟墓。然后他们被按坐在坑前，每五个人一组被刺刀刺死，三个步兵各刺一人，这是一个可怕的景象。看到泥土堆在受害者身上，而有些人还在挣扎，甚至试图从坟墓里爬出来，看到一些人从坟墓里爬起来，真是太可怕了。我们的人表现得像野蛮人。
He and a couple of others tried to restrain the people doing it, but it was impossible. And he goes on to say, there was an execution place at the edge of the woods behind the monastery. The Serbs had to dig their own graves. Then they were sat down in front of the pit and bayoneted five at a time, Three infantrymen stabbed each, a gruesome spectacle. It was terrible to see earth being heaped on the victims while some still lived, and indeed tried to climb out of the grave and to see some of those rising from the grave. Our men behaved like savages.
我无法忍受这景象，我把他们留在那儿了。所以，你知道，奥地利-匈牙利军官自己也为此感到困扰。他们在两周内大概处决了大约 3,000 人。天哪，是的。尽管有关于军乐队和蛋糕的一切说法，奥地利军队确实有黑暗的一面。所以本我（id）和自我一样在发挥作用。是的，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德会度过疯狂的一天。
I couldn't stand the sight and I left them to it. So, you know, Austro-Hungarian officers themselves are troubled by this. They probably executed about 3,000 people in two weeks. Oh dear, yeah. For all the stuff about the military bands and the cake, There is a kind of dark side to the Austrian army. So the id, the id as well as the ego is in play. Yeah, Sigmund Freud would have a field day.
与此同时，奥地利人一直在向塞尔维亚行军。他们有一个特定的目标，那就是瓦列沃（Vallevo）的一个铁路枢纽。路上有一座森林密布的山脊，叫做塞尔山（Mount Sir）。他们在 8 月 15 日的傍晚到达了山顶。他们精疲力竭。他们非常口渴。他们非常饥饿。那天晚上有一场巨大的雷暴。
Now, meanwhile, the Austrians have been marching into Serbia. They have a particular objective in mind, which is this railway junction at a place called Vallevo. And in the way, there is this kind of heavily forested ridge called Mount Sir. And they reached the top on the late afternoon in the 15th of August. They're knackered. They're very thirsty. They're very hungry. There's a massive thunderstorm that night.
与此同时，奥地利军队已经挺进塞尔维亚。他们有一个特定的目标，也就是瓦列沃的一个铁路枢纽。而在他们前进的路上，有一座树木茂密的的山脊，叫做切尔山。他们在8月15日的傍晚抵达了山顶。他们精疲力竭。他们又渴又饿。那天晚上还下了一场特大的雷阵雨。
And in the middle of the thunderstorm, that's the problem. that's the point that the Serbs choose to strike back. And the result is total chaos. The Austrians are inexperienced. They panic. They start running away. They're kind of a huge mob of Austrians running away down this mountain. Unbelievably, they just keep running. And within four days, they've crossed the river again and they've gone back to Bosnia. So their first attempt to invade Serbia has been a ludicrous failure and a very bloody failure. The Serbs have lost 16,000 men. The Austrians have lost 30,000, including loads and loads of their officers. And in the eyes of the world, this is a terrible humiliation for them.
而正是在这场雷雨之中，问题出现了，塞尔维亚人正是在这个时候选择反击的。结果是一片混乱。奥地利军队缺乏经验，他们惊慌失措，开始逃跑。他们就像一大群乌合之众，顺着这座山逃命。难以置信的是，他们一直在逃跑。不到四天，他们又渡过河流，退回了波斯尼亚。因此，他们对塞尔维亚的第一次入侵是一场荒谬且血腥的惨败。塞尔维亚人损失了1.6万人，奥地利人损失了3万多，其中包括大量的军官。在全世界眼中，这对他们来说是奇耻大辱。
General Pottyurek has spent the whole time in Sarajevo, ironically. He says, oh, well, this wasn't my fault at all. I think it was the fault of our Czech troops, actually. They're very disloyal, they're poorly behaved the Czechs. By blaming the Czechs, he's able to cling on to his job. And straight away, he starts writing to Conrad and he says, I'd love to have another crack at the Serbs. You send me some more men and some more guns and whatnot.
讽刺的是，波蒂奥雷克将军在这期间一直待在萨拉热窝。他说，哦，这根本不是我的错。实际上，我认为这是我们捷克军队的错。捷克人非常不忠诚，表现很差。通过指责捷克人，他得以保住自己的饭碗。紧接着，他开始写信给康拉德，说，我很想再给塞尔维亚人一点颜色看看。你再派给我一些人马和火炮之类的。
Conrad says, no, I don't think so. You've had your chance. The Pottyurek is well connected at court. He gets his friends to lobby the Emperor Franz Joseph. And eventually he's given permission to have another crack at the Serbs. So, at dawn on the 14th of September, he has a second go. Once again, they cross the rivers into Serbia from Bosnia. This time, the Serbs have dug trenches.
康拉德说，不，我看不必了。你已经有过机会了。波蒂奥雷克在朝廷里很有后台。他让他的朋友们去游说弗兰茨·约瑟夫皇帝。最终，他获得了再次打击塞尔维亚人的准许。于是，在9月14日黎明，他发起了第二次进攻。他们再次从波斯尼亚跨越河流进入塞尔维亚。这一次，塞尔维亚人已经挖好了战壕。
And it degenerates quite quickly into kind of bloody hand-to-hand trench warfare. Austrians are thrown back. Oh, no. It will not quite as chaotic as before. They say, well, we'll have another go. So in November, they have attempt number three. Now, at this point, the Serbs are absolutely exhausted themselves, and they're running out of shells. They haven't got running out of artillery. They can't really rest their troops because they're running out to mem. So slowly, painfully, the Austrians are able to inch their way forward. And the Serbs have to abandon Belgrade, and they take up a new defensive line on a river called the Colobara, which is deep inside central Serbia. So at this point, the Austrian, the
战局很快恶化成血腥的近距离战壕战。奥地利人被击退了。哦，不。情况没有之前那么混乱。他们说，好吧，我们再试一次。所以在11月，他们进行了第三次尝试。此时此刻，塞尔维亚人自己也精疲力竭，炮弹也快打光了。他们的火炮弹药告罄。他们根本无法让部队休整，因为他们人手不足。所以，奥地利人缓慢而艰难地向前推进了一小步。塞尔维亚人不得不放弃贝尔格莱德，并在科卢巴拉河（一条深入塞尔维亚中部内陆的河流）建立了一条新的防线。所以在这个时候，奥地利……
Austrians, foolishly, I think, Tom, decide to celebrate victory. They have premature victory celebrations. The emperor sends potty or echo message of congratulations. Lots of towns name him an honorary citizen. A street in Sarajevo is renamed in his honour. Wow, that's punchy. That is, yeah. The man is basically his foolishness has caused the whole thing. It's caused the First World War, yeah. However, it will surprise you to know that the Austrians are perhaps being a little bit premature. Because that guy who they'd released the bloke with a beard and emphysema, Radimir Putnik. His emphysema's got far worse under the pressure war, so he can't breathe. We will not surrender. Exactly. But even though he can't breathe, he's still a much better
汤姆，我认为奥地利人愚蠢地决定庆祝胜利。他们举行了过早的庆祝胜利活动。皇帝给波蒂奥雷克发去了贺电。许多城镇授予他荣誉市民称号。萨拉热窝的一条街道以他的名字重新命名。哇，这可真够讽刺的。确实是这样。这个人的愚蠢基本上导致了整件事情。是的，它引发了第一次世界大战。然而，你可能会感到惊讶的是，奥地利人或许高兴得有点太早了。因为那个被他们释放的人——那个留着胡子、患有肺气肿的人，拉多米尔·普特尼克。在战争的压力下，他的肺气肿恶化得厉害，以至于呼吸困难。我们绝不投降。没错。但尽管他呼吸困难，他依然是一个比任何奥地利指挥官都优秀得多的……
commander than any of the Austrians. So he knows that the Austrians have now, they've gone on the attack, they've sustained massive casualties, more than 130,000 casualties. They haven't got any food, they're ravaged by lice, they're miles ahead of their supply lines, they've got no shoes, but their fancy uniforms are in rags. They're very miserable, and actually the weather has now changed. This is the thing about the Eastern Front. There's only two weather settings. It's either unbelievably suffocatingly hot, or you're dying of frostbite.
指挥官。所以他知道奥地利人现在已经发起进攻，他们蒙受了巨大的伤亡，伤亡人数超过13万人。他们没有食物，饱受虱子折磨，距离补给线有数英里远，没有鞋子，华丽的军服也变成了破布。他们苦不堪言，而且天气也变了。这就是东欧战场的特点。这里只有两种天气状况。要么热得令人窒息，要么你就要冻死了。
So now it's snowing. And meanwhile, Putnik has done something amazing. He's arranged with the French to have 11,000 shells imported via Sononica, Thessaloniki. They're the wrong size for the Serbian gun, so every single shell has been taken apart and reassembled and transported to the front. So late November, Putnik rallies his forces. He's basically got all the Serbian men. That's 200,000 of them. He's got 400 guns. And he has a secret weapon. And what's that, Dominic? A secret weapon is a man. It's Petar Karajorjevich, the king of Serbia. The king of Serbia. And Dominic, just a wild guess here.
所以现在开始下雪了。与此同时，普特尼克做了一件了不起的事。他通过塞萨洛尼基（索伦卡）与法国人协商进口了1.1万枚炮弹。这些炮弹的尺寸不适合塞尔维亚的大炮，因此每一枚炮弹都被拆开、重新组装并运送到前线。所以在11月下旬，普特尼克召集了他的部队。他基本上集结了所有的塞尔维亚男丁，共计20万人。他拥有400门大炮。他还有一个秘密武器。多米尼克，那是什么？秘密武器是一个人。他就是塞尔维亚国王佩塔尔·卡拉乔杰维奇。塞尔维亚国王。多米尼克，我大胆猜一下。
Yeah. From what I've previously learned about significant players in the early months of the First World War, I'm guessing he's very elderly, I'm guessing he's very melancholy, and I'm guessing that he has some terrible ailment, would I be correct? He's got rheumatism, but if you Google him, he really does have a superb moustache. And he's elderly? Yeah, he's 70. Of course.
嗯。根据我之前对第一次世界大战头几个月重要人物的了解，我猜他年纪很大，我猜他非常忧郁，我猜他患有某种可怕的疾病，我猜得对吗？他患有风湿病，但如果你在谷歌上搜索他，你会发现他确实留着一抹极棒的小胡子。而且他年纪很大？对，他70岁了。当然。
Anyway, he tours the trenches, King Petar, and he says, my children, I have learned that some among your number tire of fighting, but I shall stay to the end. And a French reporter who is there said of the Serbs, I'm sure this is true. Each of them felt his soul gripped with a furious desire to seize victory or to die for their old uncle, who had stayed there among his children, in spite of his failing health, even as the cannons roared and the bullets whistled. I mean, it's interesting, isn't it, how it mirrors the pattern of what's happened on the Western Front, that the Germans overextend their supply lines. There's an elderly man who says we're going to fight.
不管怎样，国王佩塔尔巡视了战壕，他说：“我的孩子们，我得知你们当中有些人厌倦了战斗，但我将坚守到最后。”当时在场的一位法国记者对塞尔维亚人这样评价，我确信这是真的：“每个人都感到自己的灵魂被一种强烈的渴望所攫取，那就是为了他们的老叔叔夺取胜利或战胜而死。尽管健康状况不佳，这位老叔叔依然留在他的孩子们中间，任凭大炮轰鸣，子弹呼啸。”我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？它反映了西线发生的事情的模式，即德国人过度延伸了他们的补给线。有一个老人说我们要战斗。
Yeah. Counter-attack is launched. And, I mean, we're being harsh on the Austrians, but I wonder whether it doesn't. reflect a basic fact that all the kind of armies are struggling to cope with, that the capacity for defence is vastly greater than the ability of attacking forces to break through those defences, do you think? I think that's absolutely true. Once you've got modern artillery and machine guns and things.
是的。反攻开始了。我的意思是，我们对奥地利人的评价可能有些苛刻，但我想知道这是否反映了一个基本事实，即所有军队都在艰难应对这种局面，防守的能力远远大于进攻部队突破这些防守的能力，你觉得呢？我认为绝对是这样。一旦你拥有了现代火炮、机枪这些装备。
And trenches and things. Completely true. However, I think anybody who's written about the Austrian performance in the war, so Nick Lloyd or Alexander Watson or whoever in their books, they unanimously agree that the Austrian performance is absolutely happening. Recival. Anyway, the Serbs launched their counterattack on the morning of the 3rd of December 1914. It's a foggy, snowy morning.
还有战壕之类。完全正确。然而，我认为任何写过关于奥地利在战争中表现的人，比如尼克·劳埃德、亚历山大·沃森或他们的书中的任何人，都一致认为奥地利军队的表现简直是惨不忍睹。糟透了。无论如何，塞尔维亚人在1914年12月3日清晨发动了反攻。这是一个有雾且下雪的早晨。
They start with the shells, but the Austrians weren't expecting. Then they charge. There's a brilliant description, actually, in Nick Lloyd's Eastern Front Book. The battle goes on into the night. There's kind of hand grenades exploding. There's chutes charging. There's machine gun fire. The Austrians are losing more and more men.
他们首先开炮，而奥地利人对此毫无防备。接着他们发起冲锋。尼克·劳埃德的东欧战场一书中有对这一幕精彩的描述。战斗一直持续到深夜。手榴弹在爆炸，步兵在冲锋，机枪在扫射。奥地利人损失了越来越多的人。
Basically, they start going backwards. And day after day, they go backwards. By the 9th of December, they're falling back into Belgrade. And then five days later, just say, okay, the game is up again, and they withdraw across the River Sava, across the Danube, back into imperial territory. Unbelievably, even as Serbian troops are marching through the centre of Belgrade, being cheered as liberators, pottyurek is right into Vienna, saying,
基本上，他们开始节节败退。日复一日，他们不断后退。到12月9日，他们已经退回了贝尔格莱德。五天后，他们再次宣布大势已去，并撤退跨越萨瓦河、跨越多瑙河，退回了帝国境内。难以置信的是，就在塞尔维亚军队穿过贝尔格莱德市中心、被欢呼为解放者时，波蒂奥雷克却写信给维也纳说：
I'd love to have another go. Oh, no, a fourth go. Yeah. You've got to admire his self-confidence, I suppose. Exactly. Even the emperor says, no, no, no, enough is enough. And actually, just before Christmas, he's sacked. And I think it's fair to say he's had a very disappointing six months.
我很想再试一次。哦，不，第四次尝试。是的。我想你不得不佩服他的自信。没错。甚至连皇帝都说，不，不，不，够了。事实上，就在圣诞节前夕，他被解职了。我想公平地说，他这六个月过得非常令人失望。
Yeah, that CV is going to take quite a lot of work. Exactly. Actually, I didn't quote this actually. But I think it's maybe Max Asteen's book, there's a line from him where he says he's so disappointed to have been sacked. He says, I'm very disappointed because I now won't have the opportunity to clear my name of the very cruel and foolish things that people are saying about me. Well, for Austria, this could not have been a more terrible fiasco. They'd sent 462,000 men to fight in the Balkans, of whom 273,000 have become casualties. Wow.
是的，那份简历恐怕得费好大功夫才能修饰好了。没错。其实，我刚才没引用这句话。但我想这可能是马克斯·阿斯特恩书中的一句话，里面有一段话大致是说，他对被解职感到非常失望。他说：“我感到非常失望，因为我再也没有机会洗清人们对我那些非常残酷和愚蠢的言论了。”好吧，对奥地利来说，这简直是一场再糟糕不过的惨败了。他们派出了46.2万人到巴尔干作战，其中27.3万人伤亡。哇。
Oh, my God. So over half. Yeah. Now, that includes tens of thousands killed, a far greater number who are missing, and tens and tens of thousands who are dead of disease, of one kind or another. And the real nightmare for the Austrians is that now that their weakness has been exposed for everybody to see, the vultures are circling. And one vulture above all. and that is their supposed ally Italy. However, there is one bit of good news for the central powers in the East.
哦，天哪。所以超过了一半。是的。现在，这包括数万名阵亡者，数量远超于此的失踪人员，以及成千上万死于各种疾病的人。对奥地利人来说，真正的噩梦是，既然他们的弱点已经暴露无遗，秃鹫们便开始盘旋了。而其中最大的一只秃鹫，就是他们所谓的盟友意大利。不过，对于东方的同盟国来说，还有一个好消息。
Because although the Austrians have let themselves down, elsewhere, our old friends, the Germans, have found two very impressively efficient and ruthless commanders to lead them against the Russians. And mustachioed commanders, right? So yet more massive Teutonic mustache action to come. and we will find out who they are and what impact they have on the Eastern Front after the break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it.
因为尽管奥地利人让自己失望了，但在其他地方，我们老朋友德国人已经找到了两位能力极强、冷酷无情的指挥官来率领他们对抗俄国人。而且都是留着小胡子的指挥官，对吧？所以接下来还会有更多日耳曼式的巨大胡子大戏。中场休息后，我们将揭晓他们是谁，以及他们对东部战线产生了什么影响。本集节目由Uber赞助播出。你知道那种当你在最需要的时候有人挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要这种支持，而Uber深知这一点。
Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society.
Uber不仅提供乘车或送餐服务，它意味着无论发生什么都会鼎力相助。就像为远方的朋友在他们生病时送去热汤，在他们情绪低落时送上鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么事，你都会出现。只要有心，我们就在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。本集节目由福利学会赞助播出。
Now, Thomas, you know, in the Middle Ages, it could take you years if you're a monk to create a manuscript. You'd have to copy it out word by word, and then after all that, the margins would be ready and you'd put all kind of decorative elements and all kinds of guilt and stuff in the margins and it would look fantastic. So it might take often years to finish, but the finished product would then last for centuries. And that is pretty much what the Folio Society does today, only, of course, with slightly less parchment and fewer quills. Yes, the Folio Society takes some of the greatest works ever written. Things like George Orwell's 1984 or the quests in J.R. Tolkien or Frank Herbert's Dune and their team of editors and designers and artisans.
好了，托马斯，你知道的，在中世纪，如果你是一个修士，制作一份手稿可能需要花费你几年的时间。你必须逐字逐句地抄写，然后在此之后，还要留出空白页，并在页边空白处加上各种装饰元素以及各种金箔之类的东西，看起来会美极了。所以完成它往往需要数年的时间，但最终的成品却能流传几个世纪。这几乎就是如今福利学会所做的事情，当然，只不过羊皮纸稍微少了一点，羽毛笔也少了一些。是的，福利学会精选了有史以来最伟大的著作。比如乔治·奥威尔的《1984》、J.R.罗 Tolkien 的魔幻巨著或弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，他们的编辑、设计和工匠团队。
They craft books that are so beautiful. They're like works of art in their own right. So each one is carefully designed with slipcases, award-winning illustrations, and covers that honor the stories inside. It doesn't just protect them. So if like me and like Tom, you think that a book should look as good as it reads, then the Folio Society very much speaks your language. Explore the world's most loved stories in the most beautiful form, only at foliosociety.com. That is foliosociety.com.
他们制作的精美书籍，本身就像是艺术品。因此，每一本书都经过精心设计，配有精美的书套、屡获殊荣的插图，以及向书中故事致敬的封面。它不仅能保护书籍。所以，如果你像我和托马斯一样，认为一本书的外观应该和它的内容一样精彩，那么福利学会非常符合你的审美。探索世界上最受欢迎的故事，尽在最美的版本，仅在 foliosociety.com。网址是 foliosociety.com。
Hello everybody, it's Dominic here. Now, I'm absolutely delighted to announce that, as of now, every Friday for the next few weeks, I'll be joined by our Restis History producer and resident book lover Tabby Siret, and we'll be discussing a different book. And members of the Restis History Club can listen to this thrilling new content right away. So what we're doing is we're looking at the context
大家好，我是多米尼克。现在，我非常高兴地宣布，从现在开始，在接下来的几周里，每周五我们的历史播客制作人和常驻书迷塔比·西雷特将和我一起，我们讨论一本不同的书。“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员可以立即收听这一激动人心的新内容。所以我们要探讨的是：
when the books were written, the lives of the people who wrote them, what makes the book so brilliant and why they still matter today. We'll be digging into everything from Truman Capote's True Crime Chiller in Cold Blood to Albert Camus to Graham Stoker's horror novel, Dracula,
书籍创作时的背景、作者的人生经历、是什么让这本书如此出色以及为什么它们在今天依然重要。我们将深入探讨从杜鲁门·卡波特的真实犯罪惊悚小说《冷血》到阿尔贝·加缪，再到布拉姆·斯托克的恐怖小说《吸血鬼德古拉》，
and we'll be looking at the history behind their great books. So last week, we talked about J.R. Tolkien's The Hobbit. We looked at how it affected Tolkien's experiences in the First World War, how it reflects the sensibility of the 1920s and 1930s, how Tolkien drew on all kinds of different influences from the imperial fiction of the Victorian era to the Norse epics that he loved so much. And next week, if you don't like The Hobbit, we'll be doing something very different. We're doing Margaret Atwood's book, The Hammaid's Tale. And as a treat for our listeners, we have a short clip at the end of this episode. So you can see what you're missing.
我们将探究这些伟大名著背后的历史。所以上周，我们讨论了J.R.托尔金的《霍比特人》。我们探讨了它如何受到托尔金在第一次世界大战中经历的影响，它如何反映20世纪20年代和30年代的情感，以及托尔金如何汲取了从维多利亚时代的帝国小说到他深爱的北欧史诗等各种不同的影响。下周，如果你不喜欢《霍比特人》，我们将做一些完全不同的事情。我们将带来玛格丽特·阿特伍德的书《使女的故事》。作为对听众的福利，我们在本集节目末尾准备了一小段剪辑。这样你就能知道你错过了什么。
And if you like what you hear, you just need to sign up at the rest ishistory.com. You'll join the Rest Is History Club. You get all the amazing benefits. But above all, you get access to this thrilling new content. Enjoy. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We've been looking at Austria messing things up. Time now to look at another power messing things up.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，你只需要在therestishistory.com注册。你将加入“历史余韵”俱乐部。你将获得所有惊人的福利。但最重要的是，你可以收听这个激动人心的新内容。尽情享受吧。大家好，欢迎回到《历史余韵》。我们一直在关注奥地利把事情搞砸了。现在是时候看看另一个把事情搞砸的大国了。
And Dominic, this power is Russia. And we haven't really mentioned Russia at all, have we? which is odd because in some ways, perhaps the Russians more than any other power have responsibility for turning a Balkan crisis into a world war. Yeah, I think that's a fair case, Tom. Some listeners may disagree, but the Russians didn't have to treat Austria's attack on Serbia as the trigger for an all-out conflict. They did.
多米尼克，这个大国就是俄国。我们之前其实根本没有提到过俄国，对吧？这很奇怪，因为在某种程度上，比起其他任何大国，俄国人可能更有责任将一场巴尔干危机演变成一场世界大战。是的，我认为这个说法很公平，托马斯。有些听众可能会有不同意见，但俄国人本不必将奥地利对塞尔维亚的进攻视为全面冲突的导火索。但他们确实这么做了。
They felt that they couldn't give ground. And so they've got involved in a war, a war, which of course, in the long run, destroy the Tsarist regime and kill Nicholas II. So Russia is the world's largest country, 164. million people. It's the world's fourth biggest economy. So what are the top three? Britain, Germany, America? Yes, Britain, Germany, the United States. But not in that order, I think. I think the United States at this point is number one. And the Russians have the world's largest army. So they've got one and a half million people within another three million in reserve. This is what had always
他们觉得他们不能退让。于是他们卷入了一场战争，这场战争从长远来看，当然摧毁了沙皇政权并杀死了尼古拉斯二世。所以俄罗斯是世界上最大的国家，拥有1.64亿人口。它是世界第四大经济体。那么前三名是什么？英国、德国、美国？是的，英国、德国、美国。但我想顺序可能不是这样。我认为此时美国是第一位。俄国拥有世界上最大规模的军队。他们拥有150万现役部队，还有300万预备役部队。这就是一直以来
terrified the Germans and the Austrians. There are just so many Russians. So the supreme commander of the Russian army at this point is not the Tsar. The Tsar does become the Supreme kind of later. But at first he appoints his uncle, Grand Duke Nicolai, who is an enormous man. He's six foot six. So Peter the Great style. Peter the Great style. Like Peter the Great, he is a terrifying man. He's got a famously savage temper. And it gives you some sense of his character when I tell you that his great specialism and hobby was in breeding especially aggressive bozoi hounds. What's a bozoi hound? That's his kind of hound, very aggressive. That's clear that up, isn't it? Good. So he would take these
让德国人和奥地利人感到恐惧的原因。俄国人实在是太多了。当时俄国军队的最高指挥官并不是沙皇。沙皇后来确实成了最高统帅。但起初他任命了他的叔叔、身材魁梧的尼古拉大公，他身高六英尺六英寸（约1.98米）。彼得大帝风格的。彼得大帝风格的。就像彼得大帝一样，他是个可怕的人。他以脾气暴躁而闻名。当我告诉你他的最大特质和爱好是培育特别具有攻击性的波索依猎犬时，你大概能体会到他的性格了。什么是波索依猎犬？那是他那种猎犬，非常具有攻击性。这下说清楚了吧？很好。所以他会带着这些
Borsoy hounds hunting, and he has supposedly personally cut the throats of thousands of wolves. Wow. But no bellow action. No bellow action. And yet there is a softer side to him, because when Nicholas I second says to his uncle, says Uncle Nikolai, you know, I'd like you to be their supreme commander, he's never commanded troops in battle either. And he's very uncertain. He sort of says to everybody, God, I don't know what I'm doing here. I'm completely out's my depth. And actually, he started crying because he was so anxious. It's quite a feature again, isn't it? Unexpected feature that generals are always crying. Yeah. So their initial thought is that they will send two-thirds of their huge army south into Galicia, Poland and Ukraine. So they're dividing their forces up, which always works out well in war, doesn't it? It's always a brilliant idea.
波索依猎犬去打猎，据说他亲手割断过数千只狼的喉咙。哇。但没有咆哮行为。没有咆哮行为。然而他也有温和的一面，因为当尼古拉斯二世对他的叔叔说，尼古拉叔叔，你知道的，我希望你能成为他们的最高指挥官时，他也从未指挥过部队在战场上作战。他感到非常不安。他有点对所有人说，天哪，我不知道我在这里做什么。我完全不知所措。事实上，他当时急得都哭了。这又是一个特点，对吧？意料之外的特点，那就是将军们总是爱哭。是的。所以他们最初的想法是将庞大军队的三分之二向南派往加利西亚、波兰和乌克兰。因此他们分散了兵力，这在战争中总是行之有效的，不是吗？这总是个绝妙的主意。
They'll send them south against the Austrians, and we'll find out in their final episode of this series how they got on. But they send the other third into the German province of East Prussia. So this is the sort of very heavily forested, watery landscape of the Teutonic Knights and the Baltic Crusades. It's kind of got an odd kind of, sort of dreary romance to it, I think. So the Teutonic Knights who had been defeated in this landscape at a place called Tannenberg. They had indeed, and we will be talking about that. You might say, this is very foolish. The Germans have the world's best army.
他们将向南派兵对付奥地利人，我们将在本系列的最后一集中了解他们的战果。但他们把另外三分之一的兵力派往了德国的东普鲁士省。所以这里是条顿骑士团和波罗的海十字军东征那片森林密布、水网交织的地貌。我认为它带有一种奇怪的、某种略显沉闷的浪漫色彩。条顿骑士团曾在这个地形上的一个叫坦能堡的地方被击败。确实如此，我们接下来会讨论这一点。你可能会说，这太愚蠢了。德国拥有世界上最好的军队。
Why would you take them on with only a third of your own? And the reason, as so often the French are the real villains in all this. The French have basically made the Russians promise to force the Germans to fight on two fronts. So the Russians are doing this to please the French. Basically because there's a load of lakes in the middle of East Prussia called the Missouri lakes, this kind of chain of little lakes. And they're going to send one army around the north and one army around the south. So the one that will go north is the first army.
为什么你只用三分之一的兵力去迎战他们？原因在于，正如人们常说的那样，法国人才是这一切的真正罪魁祸首。法国人基本上迫使俄国人承诺迫使德国人在两线作战。所以俄国人这么做是为了取悦法国人。基本上是因为东普鲁士中部有一大片湖泊，叫做马祖里湖群，这是一串小湖泊。他们打算派出一支军队绕过北部，另一支军队绕过南部。向北进发的将是第一军。
And this is commanded confusingly by a general called Paul von Renenkamp. He's the Russian commander, just to be clear. Yes, he's the Russian commander. He obviously has a German name, because again, this is a feature of the events of 1914. He is a Baltic German baron, and he has, I think, the outstanding moustache in history. I think he's the winner. If people Google him, let me look it up. Wow, that is impressive.
令人困惑的是，这支军队由一位名叫保罗·冯·伦宁坎普的将军指挥。他就是俄国指挥官，为了说清楚这一点。是的，他就是俄国指挥官。他显然有一个德国名字，因为这也是1914年事件的一个特点。他是波罗的海德意志男爵，我认为他拥有历史上最出色的胡子。我认为他是赢家。如果人们在谷歌上搜索他，让我查一下。哇，这太令人印象深刻了。
That's enormous. Yeah, there you go. It's like a musk rat. He's great. I think he's great. He's not a very good general, but he's got a... to go on the moustache front. And the competition is very heavy at this time.
太惊人了。对，就是这样。它就像一只麝鼠。他很棒。我觉得他很棒。他不是一个很好的将军，但他在小胡子方面很有造诣。而且当时竞争非常激烈。
It's very fierce, but not from his colleague. So the second army, which will go south around the lakes, is commanded by a guy called Alexander Sampsonov. So he's from Kherson in Ukraine. He has a beard unusually. And he looks very like, I think, Nick Timothy, the conservative MP and former guru of Theresa May. Which is to say he looks a little bit like Nicholas II.
非常激烈，但不是来自他的同事。因此，第二集团军将绕过湖泊向南挺进，由一个叫亚历山大·萨姆索诺夫的人指挥。所以他来自乌克兰的赫尔松。他留着不寻常的胡子。我觉得他长得很像尼古丁·蒂莫西，保守党议员兼特蕾莎·梅的前导师。也就是说，他有点像尼古拉二世。
Yeah, a little bit, actually. Yeah. So now he, there's always a little nice detail with these guys. Sampsonov has horrendous asthma. He has really, really bad asthma. What is it with generals and terrible breathing? So he can't really breathe either. Anyway.
对，其实有点像。对。所以现在他，这些家伙身上总有一个不错的小细节。萨姆索诺夫患有可怕的哮喘。他有非常非常严重的哮喘。将军们和糟糕的呼吸是怎么回事？所以他实际上也喘不过气来。无论如何。
Shouldn't laugh. On the 17th of August, the Russians set off. Renan Kampf goes first and Sampsonoff will follow further south from Wilson. They're a colourful host because most of them are peasants. peasant infantry, but they have kind of Turkmen and Kalmic cavalry with yellow robes and sheepskin hats. There's Cossacks with kafftans and kind of there's boots that go up at the end. So for fans of exotic orientalism, it's a tremendous show. Well, it's amusing for us, but for the people of East Prussia, it's awful. Alexander Watson, who's written a couple
不应该笑。8月17日，俄国人出发了。雷嫩坎普夫先走，萨姆索诺夫将从威尔逊以南更远的地方跟随。他们是一支多姿多彩的军队，因为他们大多数是农民。农民步兵，但他们有穿着黄袍和羊皮帽的土库曼和卡尔梅克骑兵。有穿着长袍的哥萨克人，还有靴子向上翘起的靴子。所以对于异国东方主义的粉丝来说，这是一场巨大的演出。好吧，对我们来说这很有趣，但对东普鲁士人民来说，这太可怕了。亚历山大·沃森写了几个
of brilliant books about the Eastern Front, he says, this event, which is barely known in the West is a defining experience for a generation of Germans. So we don't often think of Germany being invaded in the First World War, but when the Russians cross the border into East Prussia, this is unbelievably traumatic for the people of Germany because the Russians advanced with unbridled ferocity. Three-fifths of the small towns in East Prussia were looted and burned. More than a quarter of the farms were burned to the ground. Again, as so often, the obsession with partisans.
关于东部战线的精彩书籍，他说，这个在西方鲜为人知的事件对一代德国人来说是一次具有决定性意义的经历。所以我们并不经常认为德国在第一次世界大战中被入侵，但当俄国人越过边境进入东普鲁士时，这对德国人民来说是难以置信的创伤，因为俄国人以肆无忌惮的凶猛前进。东普鲁士五分之三的小城镇遭到洗劫和烧毁。四分之一以上的农场被烧为平地。同样，如往常一样，对游击队的痴迷。
Grand Duke Nikolai said any village where our troops are attacked in any way must be completely destroyed. They shoot about 1,500 people. And I think the reason there's not more is because these pressures is not very densely populated. They would have shot more if there were more people. These are the bloodlands then of Timothy Snyder's book. Yeah. Probably the worst place to be born in the 20th century. Do you know, it's also the worst place to be an enthusiastic cyclist.
尼古拉大公说，任何我们的军队受到某种程度袭击的村庄都必须被彻底摧毁。他们枪杀了大约1500人。我想没有更多人的原因是因为东普鲁士人口不是很稠密。如果人更多，他们会枪杀更多人。这些就是蒂莫西·斯奈德书中的血腥之地。是的。可能是20世纪出生最糟糕的地方。你知道，这也是当一个热情的骑自行车的人最糟糕的地方。
Like your great uncle, is it? Yeah. Why? Because to have a bicycle in the Russian Empire, bicycles were a luxury and they were very unusual. Russian soldiers, when they saw people on bicycles, assumed that they were military machines and shot their riders because they said, these people are clearly partisans. One in 20 of the people killed by the Russians was riding a bike. Very glad that great Uncle Charlie was that on the Eastern Front?
就像你伟大的叔叔一样，是吗？对。为什么？因为在俄罗斯帝国拥有一辆自行车，自行车是奢侈品，而且非常罕见。俄罗斯士兵看到骑自行车的人时，以为他们是军用机器，并枪杀了骑手，因为他们说，这些人显然是游击队员。被俄国人杀害的人中，每20人中就有一个在骑自行车。很高兴伟大的查理叔叔在东部战线吗？
Yeah. You wouldn't have fared well. It's rare that you hear people say they wish that their ancestors happening on the Eastern Front in either world war. Anyway, at first the Russians advance and they think, oh, this is a good. going brilliantly. East Prussia has this army guarding it called the eighth army, German. They're hugely outnumbered. They have an elderly commander called General von Pritvitz. Does he have breathing problems and a large moustache? I think he has commanding problems actually rather than breathing problems. Because when his men first meet the Russians at a place called Gunbun, a village, the Germans end up
是的。你不会过得很好。很少听到有人说他们希望他们的祖先在任何一次世界大战中碰巧在东部战线。无论如何，起初俄国人前进，他们认为，哦，这很好。进展顺利。东普鲁士有一支名为第八集团军的德国军队在保卫它。他们的人数远逊于对方。他们有一位名叫普里特维茨将军的老指挥官。他有呼吸问题和大胡子吗？我想他实际上有指挥问题而不是呼吸问题。因为当他的手下在一个叫根本的村庄第一次遇到俄国人时，德国人最终
retreating in confusion and Pritvitz says, oh, we're doomed. We're never going to beat the Russians. The Russians, meanwhile, are cock a hoop. So Renencamp's men, they've never seen. such wealth as they're seeing on these German farms. So they're absolutely, all these stories about them stuffing themselves with ham and goose. They find a cheese factory. Oh, yeah, this is a great story. And they loot this cheese factory. So all the Russians, all the cavalry are riding with an entire cheese dangling from their saddles.
在混乱中撤退，普里特维茨说，哦，我们完了。我们永远不会战胜俄国人。与此同时，俄国人兴高采烈。所以雷嫩坎普夫的手下，他们从未见过。他们在这些德国农场里看到的这种财富。所以他们绝对，所有关于他们用火腿和鹅塞满自己的故事。他们发现了一个奶酪工厂。哦，是的，这是一个伟大的故事。他们洗劫了这个奶酪工厂。所以所有的俄国人，所有的骑兵都在马鞍上挂着一块整奶酪骑马。
And one of them said later, a cavalry man is used to many odors, but never did we smell as we did then. So a stink of cheese. Now, at this point, the Russians make some terrible mistakes. First of all, Renen Camp, he's the guy who's gone. north with the first army. He says, well, we're doing splendidly. Let's have a little rest now and gather some supplies. Now, Sampsov is going around the lakes to the south. He has a very tense relationship with Renan Kampf, and he wants in on this cheese action and on the spoils and stuff.
其中一人后来笑着说，骑兵习惯了许多气味，但我们从未像那时那样闻到过气味。所以是一股奶酪味。现在，在这个时候，俄国人犯了一些可怕的错误。首先，雷嫩坎普夫，他是去的人。带着第一集团军向北。他说，好吧，我们干得好。现在休息一下，收集一些补给。现在，萨姆索诺夫正绕过南部的湖泊。他和雷嫩坎普夫的关系非常紧张，他想参与这种奶酪行动和战利品之类的东西。
And he says to his men, come on, keep going south around the lakes. Now, both of them assume the Germans are finished. And indeed, the German commander Pritvitz, he thinks that. He thinks that. He rang Malka and on the 21st of August. He said, my men are as good as done. But it's interesting, isn't it? This is exactly the same time as the Germans are making an identical mistake about the French and the British on the Western Front. Yeah. It goes back to the point you made in the first half of this episode, Tom. If you're attacking in the First World War, you're generally in trouble. Yeah, you're losing. Anyway, Pritvitz said, you know, we're doomed, let's all withdraw. This is a terrible disaster. The very next afternoon of a Volcker
他对他的手下说，来吧，继续向南绕过湖泊。现在，他们俩都以为德国人完了。事实上，德国指挥官普里特维茨也是这么想的。他是这么想的。他在8月21日给毛奇打电话。他说，我的人已经差不多完了。但这很有趣，不是吗？这与德国人在西线对法国人和英国人犯下完全相同的错误的时间完全一样。是的。这就回到了你在本集前半部分提出的观点，汤姆。如果你在第一次世界大战中进攻，你通常会有麻烦。是的，你在输。无论如何，普里特维茨说，你知道，我们完了，让我们都撤退吧。这是一场可怕的灾难。就在第二天下午，沃克
sent a message to Pritvitz's headquarters, which pleasingly was at Marionburg, beside the vast fortress of the Teutonic Knights. So today that's Malbork in Poland. I've been to this castle. It's one of my favorite castles. Huge brick castle. Brilliant. Yeah, it's the one built out of brick, isn't it?
向普里特维茨的总部发了一条消息，令人高兴的是，该总部位于条顿骑士团巨大堡垒旁的马林堡。所以今天是波兰的马尔堡。我去过这座城堡。这是我最喜欢的城堡之一。巨大的砖砌城堡。太棒了。是的，是用砖建成的那个，对吧？
Yeah. Exactly. Pritvitz kind of opens the message. And the message basically says, you're fired. Because in his place, Mulk is going to appoint somebody who he thinks can win the war against the Russians.
是的。没错。普里特维茨打开了这条消息。消息基本上是说，你被解雇了。因为毛奇将任命一个他认为能够赢得对俄战争的人来取代他的位置。
And he's got another elderly general in mind. And this is the top Teutonic walrus, hewn from the oak of Prussia, Paul von Hindenborg. Right, yes, who will play a key role in the story of the Nazis. So Hindenburg is of
他心中还有另一位老将军。这就是顶级的条顿海象，由普鲁士的橡木雕刻而成，保罗·冯·兴登堡。对，是的，他将在纳粹的故事中发挥关键作用。所以兴登堡是
classic Juncker stock. That means he's part of the kind of Prussian land-owning classes. He'd fought in the Franco-Prussian War. He then taught at the War Academy and he had retired in 1911. So since then,
典型的容克血统。这意味着他是普鲁士地主阶级的一部分。他参加过普法战争。后来他在战争学院任教，并于1911年退休。所以从那时起，
he's been sitting at home in Hanover, basically smoking his pipe and reading the paper. And when war broke out, he waited for the call and it never came and he was gutted and he complained.
他一直坐在汉诺威的家中，基本上是抽着烟斗读着报纸。当战争爆发时，他等待着召唤，但召唤从未到来，他感到非常沮丧并抱怨。
He said, I sit like an old woman in front of the stove. I've got nothing to do. And Malka sends him this telegram. It reached Hanover on the afternoon of the 22nd of August. I want you to go and command the army in East Prussia. Hindenburg sent a brilliant,
他说，我像个老太婆一样坐在炉子前面，无所事事。接着小奇Malka给兴登堡发了这份电报，电报于8月22日下午到达汉诺威：我希望你去东普鲁士指挥军队。兴登堡回复了一个极其精彩、简短的两个词：我准备好了。
terse, two-word reply, I'm ready. And then at four o'clock in the morning, he went down to Hanover station. There was a special train waiting for him, a darkened platform. He gets on this train, and on the train is his new chief of staff,
然后在凌晨四点，他来到汉诺威车站。那里有一辆专列在等他，月台上一片漆黑。他上了这列火车，车上坐着他的新参谋长，
and then they head off east. Everybody said of Hindenburg. The thing about Hindenburg that's great, He's very meticulous. He takes his work seriously, but he's a bit like General Jophe in France. He's completely unflappable. He will never panic.
然后他们向东驶去。所有人都这样评价兴登堡：兴登堡最棒的地方在于他非常一丝不苟。他对待工作很认真，但有点像法国的霞飞将军，完全沉着冷静，绝不会惊慌失措。
He's very good-humoured. His men like him. And he will never, never collapse in a kind of hissy fit. But actually, Mulker only wants Hindenberg as a figurehead. There's a claim that actually Hindenberg only got the job because his house was on the same train line that the chief of staff would be taking because it's the chief of staff that Malka really wants.
他幽默感十足，部下都很喜欢他。而且他绝对、绝对不会大发脾气。但实际上，小奇Malka只想要兴登堡当个吉祥物。有种说法是，兴登堡之所以能得到这份工作，实际上只是因为他的房子正好在参谋长要坐的那条铁路线附近，因为小奇Malka真正想要的是参谋长。
And this is a younger man, Eric Ludendorff, 49 years old, also a key figure, conquering Liege. Who we met earlier, didn't we, in the series? Yes, exactly. He is not a younger. He's not from the landowning classes. He's from a merchant family in what's now Poland. And he'd become this brilliant military prodigy. The reason that he's not appointed is because he's not of the right class.
这是一个更年轻的人，埃里希·鲁登道夫，49岁，也是一个关键人物，曾征服列日。这就是我们之前在节目中遇到过的那个人，对吧？是的，完全正确。他不是年轻人。他不是地主阶级出身，而是来自现波兰境内的一个商人家庭。他成为了一个杰出的军事天才。他没有被任命的原因是他出身不对。
And the Kaiser doesn't like him, does he? Because he sees him as a parvenu. The irony, of course, the Kaiser thinks that he's the kind of. a man who would wear the wrong shoes. He probably does, but it doesn't matter because he's a very good general. Everybody has always said of Ludendorff, he is the great star of the German army. He is the rising star. He's the sort of future England captain.
而且德皇不喜欢他，对吧？因为德皇把他看作暴发户。当然，具有讽刺意味的是，德皇认为他是那种会穿错鞋子的人。他可能确实会，但没关系，因为他是一个非常优秀的将军。每个人都一直称赞鲁登道夫，说他是德国军队中耀眼的明星，是新星，有点像是未来的英格兰队长。
Isn't that what people say about cricketers? Yes. Yeah. They'd also said, however, that he's an incredibly glacial and ruthless person. Well, the two aren't contradictory, surely. No, no, no. Of course not. Of course not.
人们不都是这么评价板球运动员的吗？是的。是的。然而，人们也说他是一个极其冷酷无情的人。嗯，这两者并不矛盾，对吧？不，不，不。当然不。当然不。
He is a serious person. His wife said of him, she'd never known him to laugh or make a joke of any kind. She also always called him Ludendorff by his surname. I like that. But that said, actually we can overdo this because his men were very loyal to him and they adored him. A general can be glacial and never laugh and have his wife call him by his surname. Yeah. But if these are qualities that make it likely that you as a private soldier are going to survive a battle, of course you're going to love him.
他是一个严肃的人。他的妻子评价他说，从来没见过他笑或者开任何玩笑。她也一直直呼他的姓氏鲁登道夫。我喜欢这一点。但话虽如此，其实我们也有点言过其实了，因为他的部下对非常忠诚而且崇拜他。一个将军可以冷酷无情、从不微笑，还可以让妻子直呼其姓。是的。但如果这些品质能让你作为一个普通士兵在战斗中生还，你当然会爱戴他。
Yeah, of course. As you said, Ludendorff has been the big star at the war's first weeks. He captured Lijge. The Kaiser, just before he got on the train, actually gave him the highest award for Gallantry. Paul Omerit, the Blue Max, as it's called. And Molka said to Ludendorff, you are the only man who can save East Prussia. You're the only man I trust.
是的，当然。正如你所说，鲁登道夫一直是战争前几周的明星。他攻占了列日。德皇在上火车前，甚至授予了他最高英勇勋章——“功勋勋章”（Pour le Mérite），也就是所谓的“蓝色马克斯”。小奇Malka对鲁登道夫说，你是唯一能拯救东普鲁士的人，你是我唯一信任的人。
Go and do it. So he and Hindenburg get on the train, they go off to East Prussia. Now, meanwhile, Sampsonoff is still coming with 180,000 men south around the lakes. It will amaze people to hear there's an atmosphere of general chaos in the Russian advance.
去完成它吧。于是他和兴登堡上了火车，前往东普鲁士。与此同时，萨姆索诺夫正率领18万大军向南绕过湖泊。听到俄军推进时弥漫着一片混乱的气氛，人们会感到惊讶。
They don't have enough trucks. Half the men have barely trained. They've got terrible intelligence, so they've got no idea where the Germans are or basically where they are. where they're going, any of this. I don't want to engage in national stereotyping. No, never on this show.
他们没有足够的卡车。半数士兵几乎没有接受过训练。他们的情报糟透了，所以他们根本不知道德国人在哪里，或者基本上他们自己在哪里，要去哪里，什么都不知道。我不想搞民族刻板印象。不，在这个节目里绝对不会。
But I'm going to. Would it be fair to say that it is a clash between Prussian efficiency and Russian chaos? Yes, basically, it would be completely fair. So actually, Hindenberg and Ludendorf have come up with a plan on the train. They'll basically send some cavalry north. So Renen Kampf thinks they're coming north and he won't keep coming. I mean, well, they'll use the trains to move all of their rest of their men. against Sampsonoff in the south.
但我今天要搞。说这是一场普鲁士效率与俄国混乱之间的冲突，公平吗？是的，基本上，这完全公平。所以实际上，兴登堡和鲁登道夫在火车上想出了一个计划。他们基本上会派一些骑兵向北，这样伦宁坎普就会以为他们要向北进攻，从而停下前进的脚步。我是说，好吧，他们会用火车把其余的所有部队运送到南方的萨姆索诺夫那里。
Because the Germans are doing everything that the Austrians don't. The German high command have removed an incompetent commander, replaced them with an efficient commander. They're using their trains to their best ability. Exactly. They have good intelligence. Yeah. So it's looking good for them.
因为德国人在做奥匈帝国不做的一切。德国最高指挥部免除了一个无能指挥官的职务，换上了一个高效的指挥官。他们充分利用了火车的效能。完全正确。他们情报准确。是的。所以他们的形势看起来很不错。
Completely. So on the 23rd of August, they get to the Marienburg, the castle of the Teutonic Knights. Hindenburg goes for a walk around the castle. And actually, again, if you Google it, you can see some of the propaganda postcards that were produced of Hindenberg. Hindenburg kind of outside this castle, thinking about the Teutonic Knights, whether he did this or not, I don't know. Anyway, the next day they tore the front, Hindenburg and Ludendorf.
完全如此。所以在8月23日，他们到达了条顿骑士团城堡所在地马林堡。兴登堡在城堡周围散步。而且同样，如果你用谷歌搜索，你可以看到当时印制的一些关于兴登堡的宣传明信片。兴登堡站在城堡外，思考着条顿骑士团的历史，他到底有没有这样做，我不知道。无论如何，第二天他们前往前线，兴登堡和鲁登道夫。
There's a proper war zone. There's refugees everywhere. There's columns of black smoke rising over villages in the distance, all of this. They go past this village called Tannenberg, and both generals know their history, because it was here in 1410 that the Teutonic Knights had lost a titanic battle with the Poles and the Lithuanians. And as they're driving back from Tannenberg, they get brilliant news. The Germans have intercepted two Russian radio messages. Russian communications are terrible. They're not properly disguising their messages.
那是一个真正的战区。到处都是难民。远处的村庄上空升起滚滚黑烟，诸如此类。他们路过一个叫坦能堡的村庄，两位将军都熟知历史，因为正是在这里，1410年条顿骑士团在与波兰人和立陶宛人的大战中惨败。当他们从坦能堡开车返回时，他们得到了一个绝佳的消息。德国人截获了两份俄国电报。俄国的通信糟透了。他们没有对电报进行妥善加密。
Renencamp and Sampsonoff are now so far apart that they cannot support each other. And Hindenberg says, well, this is our chance. We'll go for Sampsonoff. We won't just beat him. We'll annihilate him. And when he gets back home, Hindenberg is very General Jof-like, says to his officers, gentlemen, our preparations are so well in hand that we can all sleep soundly tonight. And he likes a good night's sleep, doesn't he, Hindenburg?
伦宁坎普和萨姆索诺夫现在相距太远，无法互相支援。兴登堡说，好吧，这是我们的机会。我们进攻萨姆索诺夫。我们不仅要击败他，还要消灭他。当他回到大本营时，兴登堡表现得非常有霞飞将军的风范，对他的军官们说，先生们，我们的准备工作如此充分，今晚我们都可以安稳地睡觉了。他喜欢睡个好觉，不是吗，兴登堡？
He loves a good night sleep, as we will discover. So on the 25th of August, it begins. Sampsonoff is pushing these Russians deeper and deeper into the kind of lakelands, into the forests, but he has no idea what's out there. When he hears the first reports of German attacks on the flanks, he doesn't realize that this is a trap. He says, go deeper, go deeper, keep going. Now, back at Marienburg, Ludendorf, as always, despite this glacial reputation,
正如我们将要看到的，他喜欢好好睡上一觉。因此，在8月25日，战事开始了。萨姆索诺夫正率军将这些俄军一步步逼入湖区和森林，但他对前方的情况一无所知。当他听到第一批关于德军攻击侧翼的报告时，他并没有意识到这是一个陷阱。他说，深入进去，深入进去，继续前进。现在，回到马林堡，如往常一样，尽管卢登道夫给人一种冷冰冰的印象，
he's a nervous wreck. So he's beside himself with nerves. And actually at one point, Hindenberg has to take him out of a meeting, take him for a walk to calm him down. Yeah, because Hindenberg's just puffing on his pipe. Yeah. His moustaches drooping.
但他其实已经急得焦头烂额了。他紧张得心神不宁。事实上，在某个时刻，兴登堡不得不把他拉出会议室，带他出去散步以让他平静下来。是的，因为兴登堡当时只是在悠闲地抽着烟斗。是的。他的胡须都耷拉下来了。
He's mellow. Exactly. Ludendorff is always sort of sweating and getting very overexcited. Anyway, everything is actually going according to plan. Sampsonoff is walking deeper and deeper into this trap. So two or three days he keeps going, he still doesn't realize, even as the Germans are attacking him on his flanks,
他很放松。完全如此。卢登道夫总是那种会出汗、情绪非常激动的人。无论如何，一切其实都在按计划进行。萨姆索诺夫正一步步走入这个陷阱。因此，在两三天的时间里，他一直向前推进，甚至在德军攻击他的侧翼时，他仍然没有意识到
what he's doing. And then on the 28th of August, so about four days, three or four days into this battle, he realizes that something is wrong. Sampsonov rides forward to see what's going on and he leaves his communications technology behind, which is a complete disaster for him. Now, meanwhile, the Germans are closing the trap and they're basically closing in on this army in the forest. Sampsonov's men could have maybe got out if they'd immediately withdrawn. Instead, very foolishly, they stand and fight. And that means the Germans are able to cut their lines of retreat and completely surround them. Right. And so what happens now is a total bloodbath. Thousands upon thousands of the Russians are killed. The forests are strewn with bodies. For the next two days, they try to break out. They couldn't. They're lost. They're disoriented. They're terrified. And by the 30th of August, Samsonov's men are surrendering in their thousands. Often that they're just sitting in the woods with the kind of the hands in the air, hands in their heads, thousands of them waiting to be captured.
自己在做什么。然后，在8月28日，也就是这场战役开始大约四天后，他意识到出事了。萨姆索诺夫骑马向前查看情况，却把他的通信设备落在了后面，这对他是毁灭性的打击。与此同时，德军正在收拢包围圈，基本上在森林里对这支军队完成了合围。如果萨姆索诺夫的手下当时立刻撤退，或许还能逃脱。然而，他们非常愚蠢地选择了原地抵抗。这意味着德军得以切断他们的退路，并将他们彻底包围。没错。于是，接下来发生的事情简直是一场大屠杀。成千上万的俄军士兵被杀。森林里到处都是尸体。在接下来的两天里，他们试图突围。但他们失败了。他们迷失了方向，晕头转向，恐惧万分。到了8月30日，萨姆索诺夫的部下成千上万地投降了。他们往往只是坐在树林里，双手抱头或高举双手，数以千计地等待着被俘。
The Schleifen plan had been all about trying to recreate the Battle of Cannae, Hannibal's great victory over the Romans that consisted in surrounding an army and completely annihilating it on the Western Front. But as it turns out, the Battle of Cannae is replicated on the Eastern Front at Tannenberg. Yeah, very nice. Exactly the tactic, isn't it? Yeah. Closing the pincers of the trap. Yeah. Works brilliantly. So Hindenburg and Ludendorf, we haven't actually mentioned yet our plan to do an investigative police drama.
施里芬计划的核心，其实就是试图在西线重现坎尼战役——汉尼拔对罗马人的伟大胜利，其战术就是包围一支军队并将其彻底消灭。但事实证明，坎尼战役在东线的坦能堡得到了复制。 yeah，非常巧妙。这正是那种战术，不是吗？是的。收拢包围圈。是的。效果好极了。所以兴登堡和卢登道夫——我们其实还没提到我们拍摄一部调查类警匪剧的计划。
Yeah. with them as the detectives. They're going around on trains and they're smoking pipes and then when the need for action comes, they do their stuff. I think they'd be brilliant. Yeah. But if there's also a crime, they'll solve that on the way. Anyway, they have taken 92,000 prisoners and they had never imagined such a hall.
是的，由他们俩担任侦探。他们坐着火车到处走，抽着烟斗，然后在需要采取行动的时候，大干一场。我觉得他们会棒极了。是的。不过如果有顺便发生的谋杀案，他们也会在路上顺便侦破。不管怎样，他们已经俘获了92,000名战俘，这是他们做梦也没想到的巨大收获。
The Kaiser rather lets himself down at this point. The Kaiser has a charming plan for the prisoners. He says, I've got a brilliant idea. Why don't we corral them all on the Corland Peninsula and Western Latvia and starve them all to death. And actually, even Hindenburg and Lundor so, I think that's a bit much. Samsonoff, so with his asthma, he escaped in the woods with his entourage, with his Cossack bodyguards. They left their maps behind very foolishly, so they got completely lost in the woods. And they tried to navigate using a compass, like it's basically like sort of Duke of Edinburgh Award thing
凯撒大帝在这个时候着实有些自降身份。凯撒对这些战俘有一个迷人的计划。他说，我有个绝妙的主意。我们为什么不把他们全都圈在库尔兰半岛和拉脱维亚西部，然后让他们全都被饿死呢。其实，就连兴登堡和卢登道夫都觉得，这也太极端了。萨姆索诺夫由于哮喘发作，和他的随从以及哥萨克保镖一起逃进了树林。他们非常愚蠢地把地图落下了，结果在树林里彻底迷失了方向。他们试图用指南针辨别方向，基本上就像是
that's gone horribly wrong. Gone horribly wrong, yeah. Samsonov can't breathe. He's very depressed. He says to his bodyguards, you know, the emperor trusted me. Nicola the second, how can I ever face him after this disaster? And then he basically goes off for a walk into the woods and they hear a gunshot and he shot himself. Oh God, so like Varus after using the three legions. Exactly. Exactly. Back in Germany, total ecstasy. Because this is the point at which the Battle of the Marne has started. The Western offensive is faltering. And the public are desperate for good news. Hinnenberg says to the Kaiser, could we please name this after the Battle of Tannenberg? Because of course, they went past the village. And that gives it tremendous.
爱丁堡公爵奖那种完全搞砸了的远足活动。完全搞砸了，是的。萨姆索诺夫喘不过气来。他非常沮丧。他对保镖说，你知道的，皇帝信任我，尼古拉二世，经历这场灾难后我怎么还有脸去见他？然后他独自一人走进树林散步，接着他们听到了一声枪响，他开枪自杀。天哪，这就跟遭遇瓦卢斯失去了三个军团一样。完全如此。完全如此。回到德国，是一片狂喜。因为这就是马恩河战役爆发的时刻。西线攻势正在步履维艰。而公众正急需好消息。兴登堡对凯撒说，我们能把这场战役命名为坦能堡战役吗？因为当然，他们路过了那个村庄。这赋予了它巨大的
tremendous resonance in Germany, though the Teutonic Knights have avenged their historic defeat. They've thrown back the Asiatic hordes. The homeland has been saved, all of this. The job's not completely done. Ten days later, they turn to Renenkamp in the north, his first army. They try a similar trick, actually, the same trap. This time Renenkamp is expecting it. He is able to withdraw, and so the Russians will end up withdrawing from East Prussia. However, they don't leave empty-handed. This is another aspect of the story, I think, that people don't know about, by and large in English-speaking countries. As the Russians
在德国具有巨大的历史共鸣，尽管条顿骑士团已经洗刷了他们历史上的耻辱。他们击退了亚洲游击部落。祖国得救了，诸如此类。但工作还没有完全完成。十天后，他们调头对付北面的伦宁坎普及其第一军。他们尝试了类似的诡计，实际上是同样的陷阱。这一次，伦宁坎普有所防范。他得以撤退，因此俄军最终撤出了东普鲁士。然而，他们并没有空手而归。我认为这也是故事的另一个方面，讲英语国家的人大体上对此并不了解。随着俄军
retreated, they rounded up thousands of people, basically, as hostages. So Max Hastings tells a very moving story about a family called the Shukas, who lived in a village called Popovin. There was a school teacher, his wife and two daughters. Basically, I won't tell you the whole story, but they were taken by
撤退，他们基本上把成千上万的人当作人质抓了起来。因此，马克斯·黑斯廷斯讲了一个非常感人的故事，关于一个住在波波温村的舒卡家庭。那里有一个学校老师、他的妻子和两个女儿。基本上，我不把整个故事讲完，但他们被
the Russians as hostages. They were taken off to Siberia, and they didn't get home until 1920. Okay, so again, a prefiguring there of the events of the Second World War and its aftermath. Exactly. Well, here's a real prefiguring. 10,000 Germans in total were rounded up and deported east in cattle trucks, in horrendous
俄军当作人质抓走了。他们被带到了西伯利亚，直到1920年才回到家。好吧，所以这里再次预示了第二次世界大战及其余波中的事件。完全正确。嗯，这里还有一个真正的预示。当俄军撤离东普鲁士时，共有10,000名德国人被搜捕，并用运牛车被驱逐到东部，在极其恶劣的
conditions when the Russians left East Prussia. And what is more? I mean, this was a real revelation to me, actually. Inside the Russian Empire, there were about 200,000 ethnic Germans, Russian subjects, Russian citizens. They were deported east as well. Some historians think maybe as many as half of them died from disease, cold, starvation and so on, in the years that followed. I mean, this is a story that, you know, most of us, I guess, have never heard of.
条件下度过。不仅如此！我的意思是，这对我来说真是一个重大的启示。在俄罗斯帝国境内，大约有20万名德裔少数族群，他们是俄罗斯的臣民、俄罗斯公民。他们也被驱逐到了东部。一些历史学家认为，在随后的几年里，其中多达一半的人死于疾病、寒冷、饥饿等等。我的意思是，这是一个我们大多数人从未听说过故事。
Well, this is not the end at all of the campaign in the East. No, we've got three years to go, right? Yeah. And the really confusing thing about all this is that a few weeks later, the Russians came back, and they actually won some really big victories that nobody has ever heard of. the Battle of the Vistula, the Battle of Wudge. The Battle of what? Woodch. It's an industrial town in sort of south-central Poland.
好吧，这绝不是东线战役的结束。不，我们还有三年要打，对吧？是的。所有这一切真正令人困惑的是，几周后，俄军卷土重来，他们实际上赢得了一些真正轰动的胜利，只是无人知晓。维斯瓦河战役，罗兹战役。什么战役？罗兹。这是波兰中南部的一个工业城镇。
No, I've literally never heard of that. It's spelled LODZ. You've seen that word. Lodz. Yeah, you've seen that written down. I think Lodz is how you pronounce it, Don't know. I think not, Tom. Wudge.
不，我真的从来没听说过那个。它的拼写是 LODZ。你见过那个词。罗兹。是的，你见过它的文字版。我想罗兹就是它的发音，不知道。我想不是的，汤姆。罗兹。
This is the way the Eastern Front works. Now, putting that on one side, Hindenberg and Lusendor for the huge winners from this. Hindenberg becomes a national idol, almost unmatched, I think, in any other country. So in Berlin, people put up a 39-foot wooden statue of him. This is one of the nail men. This is so interesting.
东线战役就是这样的。现在，暂且不谈这个，兴登堡和卢登道夫是这场战役的最大赢家。兴登堡成为了一个国家偶像，几乎在任何其他国家都无出其右。因此在柏林，人们为他竖起了一座39英尺高的木质雕像。这就是“钉钉子”塑像之一。这太有趣了。
You'd put up these statues made of wood and then you'd pay to hammer in a nail and the money would go to the armed forces. So there were hundreds of these nail men across Germany and Austria. You'd have Siegfried, you'd have Charlemagne, you'd have Roland, you'd have Henry the Lion. Otto the Great. Exactly. And you'd hammer in your nail and raise money for the war effort. Now, some German officers thought this was mad to give Hindenburg so much credit. They said he's basically a clapped-out pipe-smoking walrus, who's taking the credit for other people's successes.
你会竖起这些用木头制作的雕像，然后花钱把钉子敲进去，钱则会归武装部队所有。因此，在德国和奥地利各地有数百座这样的钉子塑像。你可以有齐格弗里德，可以有查理曼，可以有罗兰，可以有狮子亨利。大帝奥托。完全正确。然后你敲入你的钉子，为战争筹集资金。现在，一些德国军官认为给兴登堡如此高的声誉简直是疯了。他们说他基本上是一只只会拍手抽烟斗的海象，却在掠夺别人成功的果实。
And Ludendorff's deputy later on used to give tours of the Battle of Tannenberg. It was called Max Hoffman. And he would say, this is where Phil Marshall and Hinderberg slept before the battle. This is where he slept after the battle. And this is where he slept during the battle. Is that fair? No, actually. So, clearly, Ludendorff is the real genius.
卢登道夫的副手后来经常带人参观坦能堡战役的遗址。他叫马克斯·霍夫曼。他会说，这是陆军元帅和兴登堡在战前睡觉的地方。这是他在战后睡觉的地方。这是他在战役期间睡觉的地方。这公平吗？不，其实并不公平。所以，很显然，卢登道夫才是真正的天才。
Ludendorff is the master of detail, but Ludendorff is flaky and neurotic. Hindenberg, with his unflappability and he's jovial and stuff and his pipe smoking, he's the perfect foil. So it's the way they work together. And this is what makes them such a brilliant crime-busting team. Correct. It's like Poirotin-Hastings or Inspector Morse and Lewis or Holmes and Watson. Yeah, the quiet, unflappable old pro puffing on his pipe,
卢登道夫是细节大师，但卢登道夫情绪多变且神经质。兴登堡沉着冷静、性格随和、抽着烟斗，他是完美的衬托。这就是他们合作的方式。这也是他们成为如此出色的破案搭档的原因。没错。这就像波洛与黑斯廷斯，或者莫斯探长与刘易斯，或者福尔摩斯与华生。是的，那个冷静、沉着的老手叼着烟斗，
and the eager young deputy who knows all about kind of microscopes and bloodstains and fingerprints and things. And the trouble is, of course, they've been tarnished by their later conduct in the 1920s and 30s when they did behave disgracefully. Well, Ludendorf, worse than Hindenburg. Yeah, Ludendorf, worse than Hinderberg. Exactly. However, I think that makes it a tough sell to a streaming giant.
而那个对显微镜、血迹、指纹等了如指掌的急切年轻副手。当然，问题在于，他们在20世纪20和30年代后期的糟糕表现玷污了他们的名声，当时他们的确行为不端。嗯，卢登道夫比兴登堡更糟。是的，卢登道夫比兴登堡更糟。完全正确。然而，我认为这对于流媒体巨头来说很难卖得出去。
Yes, yes. Anyway, by the end of the year, Eric von Falkenheim, who became the German Supreme Commander, He gives them a completely free hand in the East. And they set up something called Oberost. And that basically meant that they were now military dictators, these two guys, of the Baltic and of Belarus and Eastern Poland, of the areas that were occupied by the Germans. And some historians say this is a dry run for Nazism
是的，是的。不管怎样，到了今年年底，成为了德国最高指挥官的埃里克·冯·法金汉，给了他们在东部完全自由的行动权。他们建立了一个名为“东线总司令部”（Oberost）的机构。这基本上意味着这两个人现在成为了波罗的海、白俄罗斯和波兰东部这些被德军占领地区的军事独裁者。一些历史学家认为这是纳粹主义的一次彩排，
because they behave very harshly and repressively and they have total contempt for the Slavs. I don't think that's fair. I don't think it is a dry run for Nazism. I think although they are repressive and ruthless, they're not genocidal. They don't have any program of kind of racial hygiene, as the Nazis would have called it. They're killing people in the East, but not for Nazi reasons.
因为他们行为严厉、采取镇压手段，并且对斯拉夫人充满彻底的蔑视。我不认为这公平。我不认为这是纳粹主义的彩排。我认为尽管他们严厉且冷酷，但他们并非种族灭绝主义者。他们没有任何像纳粹那样称之为什么种族卫生的计划。他们在东部杀人，但不是出于纳粹的原因。
Yeah, exactly. They're killing people for military reasons. Now, the Kaiser pretended he was thrilled by all this. He visited Obos to give them promotions. So Hinderberg became a field martian and so on. But the Kaiser is absolutely smoldering with jealousy. He's really jealous of Vindenberg, and he absolutely despises Lutendorf. he says he's a dubious character eaten away by personal ambition.
是的，完全正确。他们出于军事原因杀人。现在，凯撒假装对这一切兴奋不已。他访问了东线总司令部，授予他们晋升。因此兴登堡成为了陆军元帅等等。但凯撒内心充满了嫉妒。他真的很嫉妒兴登堡，并且极度鄙视卢登道夫。他说他是一个被个人野心吞噬的可疑人物。
What great things has he supposed to have accomplished? I mean, that's rich coming from the Kaiser. Well, I mean, defeat the Russians. Yeah, defeat the Russians, exactly. And of course, the great irony is that by the end of the war, the Kaiser will become their puppet. Because that's the real legacy of the Battle of Tannenberg. It gives power to these two men who think the war can be won on the battlefield,
他到底取得了什么伟大的成就？我的意思是，这话从凯撒嘴里说出来真是滑稽。好吧，我的意思是，打败了俄军。是的，打败了俄军，完全正确。当然，最大的讽刺是，到了战争结束时，凯撒将成为他们的傀儡。因为这才是坦能堡战役真正的遗产。它把权力交给了这两个认为战争可以在战场上赢得、
not with a negotiated settlement. So you could argue that in the long run, Tannenberg is a disaster for Germany. They would be better for the Germans not to have won it in a way because their war would have been over more quickly, perhaps with some form of negotiation, who knows. And in the very long run, Tannenberg has a properly bailful afterlife. Because in 1927, the Germans built this huge memorial
而不是通过谈判解决的人。所以你可以争辩说，从长远来看，坦能堡对德国是一场灾难。对德国人来说，当初没赢说不定更好，因为他们的战争可能会更快结束，或许能通过某种形式的谈判解决，谁知道呢。从极长远的角度来看，坦能堡留下了真正恶劣的后世影响。因为在1927年，德国人在战场上建造了这个巨大的纪念碑，
on the battlefield with eight towers, was modelled on a cross-Feternia-tutonic castle and the castle of Frederick II in Apulia in Italy. Hindenburg dedicated it personally before thousands. thousands and thousands of veterans. And he gave this incredibly nationalistic speech in which he said, the First World War was the Noble Crusade. You know, we were on the right side. For the Nazis, Tannenberg was a huge deal. In the first year, Hitler went, all the big names went. They had torchlit parades. When Hindenburg died in 1934, he was buried there. An even bigger deal,
拥有八座塔楼，仿照条顿十字骑士城堡以及意大利普利亚的腓特烈二世城堡建造。兴登堡在数千名老兵面前亲自为其揭幕。他发表了一篇极其民族主义的演讲，在演讲中他说，第一次世界大战是一场高尚的十字军东征。你知道的，我们站在正义的一边。对纳粹来说，坦能堡是一件大事。第一年，希特勒去了，所有的大人物都去了。他们举行了火炬游行。当兴登堡于1934年去世时，他被埋葬在那里。规模更宏大，
more torchlit parades. There was a shrine, basically a Nazi shrine with these two huge granite soldiers called the Eternal Watch. Oh, so like the Valia de los Caedos. Yeah. The kind of fascist memorial to Franco in Spain. Or like the towers of the Argonath in the Lord of the Rings. You know, those two figures over the river Anduin. Anyway.
更多的火炬游行。那里有一座神殿，基本上是一座纳粹神殿，里面有两尊被称为“永恒守望者”的巨大花岗岩士兵雕像。哦，就像烈士谷一样。是的。西班牙对弗朗哥的法西斯纪念碑。或者像《指环王》中阿尔贡奇尔的巨像。你知道安都因河上的那两尊雕像吗？不管怎样。
But they're goodies, aren't they? They are goodies. So it's a terrible comparison. Yeah. But as the Germans were retreating from East Prussia in 1945, the entire complex was blown up by the German soldiers. And then every single trace was erased. by the Polish communists afterwards, said that today nothing of it remains at all.
但他们是正面人物，不是吗？他们是正面人物。所以这个比喻太糟糕了。是的。但当德国人在1945年从东普鲁士撤退时，整个建筑群被德国士兵炸毁了。然后每一处痕迹都被抹去了。
That is looking far ahead into the future. But for now, we're still in 1914. So in today's episode, just to sum up, the Austrians have really messed things up in Serbia. The Germans have held the Russians off in East Prussia. But Dominic, is there more drama to come on the Eastern Front? And will it provide us with one final episode in this series on the war in 1914. It will indeed, Tom, and it's the most dramatic story of all. It is a titanic struggle in eastern Poland and Ukraine between the Austrians and the Russians, and at its centre is the longest siege of the entire conflict, the Stalingrad of the First World War. And this, Tom, will be the beginning of the end for the Habsburg Empire. I can't wait to
那已经是遥远的未来了。但现在，我们仍然停留在1914年。所以在今天的节目中，简单总结一下，奥地利人在塞尔维亚把事情搞得一团糟。德国人在东普鲁士挡住了俄军。但是多米尼克，东线战场还会有更多戏剧性的事件发生吗？它会为我们提供1914年战争系列的最后一集吗？确实如此，汤姆，这是所有故事中最戏剧性的一场。这是奥地利人和俄军在波兰东部和乌克兰之间的一场泰坦式的冲突，其核心是整个冲突中历时最长的围城战——第一次世界大战的斯大林格勒。汤姆，这将是哈布斯堡王朝走向终结的开始。我等不及要
hear it, because I'm not going to be contributing to anything, because I literally have no idea what the Starlingrad of the First World War is. But Dominic, you know all of this, like the back of your hand. I'm looking forward to hearing it. Restis History Club members can hear it right away. If you would like to hear it yourself and you're not a member, then you can sign up at the rest of history.com. But for now, Fida Zane. Afida Zane. Hello, everybody. It's Dominic here. Now, as a treat for listeners, here is an extract. We promised you earlier on. From our thrilling books episodes, from our first episode. J.R. Tolkien's fantasy classic, The Hobbit. Enjoy. For a moment, he thought of plundering dragons, settling on his
听下去了，因为我什么都不会贡献，因为我真的对第一次世界大战的斯大林格勒一无所知。但是多米尼克，你对这一切了如指掌。我很期待听到它。“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员可以立即收听。如果你想自己收听而你还不是会员，那么你可以在therestofhistory.com注册。但现在，Fida Zane。Afida Zane。大家好。我是多米尼克。现在，作为给听众的福利，这是我们之前承诺过的精彩图书节目的节选。来自我们的第一期节目。J.R.R.托尔金的奇幻经典《霍比特人》。尽情享受吧。有一瞬间，他想到了掠夺成性的恶龙，在一处
quiet hill and kindling all to flames. And very quickly, he was playing Mr. Baggins, a bag end underhill again. Now, the thing is, Tolkien's writing this in the 1930s. And I think that paragraph perfectly captures the sensibility of so many British people. in the 1920s and 1930s. In other words, the First World War has happened and they've come home. And for people like Tolkien, the First World War means that they never think of war again as romantic, as glamorous, as pain-free, all of that stuff. Tolkien just wants to stay at home and tend his garden and not get involved. Now, there was a bit of him that feels pulled towards adventure and excitement, but at the same time, they're worried that if they get
宁静的山丘上安家并点燃熊熊烈火。但很快，他又开始扮演袋底洞安德希尔先生的巴金斯了。问题是，托尔金是在20世纪30年代写这部作品的。我认为这段话完美地捕捉到了许多英国人在20世纪20和30年代的心态。
involved in matters far from home. Dragons will come and, you know, set fire to their homes, their villages, their towns. And you had a fleeting mention early then in this podcast of Stanley Baldwin. And Stanley Baldwin, who's very hobbit-like. He likes a waistcoat. He's from this part of the world, from Worcestershire. He is very much a new kind of politician who's unromantic, I suppose, un-glamorous. And he famously said, you know, the bomber will always get through, as in be worried about bombing, you know, New War would be apocalyptic and all of that kind of thing. And I think Bilbo, he absolutely embodies that tension. You know, there's part of him that is pulled towards adventure and pulled towards excitement. But at the same time, he's anxious,
换句话说，第一次世界大战已经发生，他们已经回到了家。对于像托尔金这样的人来说，第一次世界大战意味着他们再也不会把战争看作是浪漫的、迷人的、无痛的，诸如此类。托尔金只想呆在家照顾他的花园，不想卷入其中。现在，他内心深处有一部分觉得自己被吸引去追求冒险和刺激，但与此同时，他们担心如果他们卷入
he's home-loving, he's frightened. He's a kind of perfect representation, I think, of the mentality of so many people of Tolkien's generation at the time that he was writing. But I also think it's interesting that obviously the Lord of the Rings was written a bit later. So when this is being written, the storm clouds of war are kind of, they're on the horizon, but they're not yet gathering above. And Bilbo isn't forced out of his comfortable life in Hobbit hole because he knows that he has to do something to save his homeland. He doesn't go because he knows there's darkness beyond the gates that he could play a part in quelling and destroying. In the Hobbit, the stakes aren't that high. There isn't an existential threat at the door yet. No. It's just
远离家乡的事情。巨龙会来，你知道的，烧毁他们的家园、村庄、城镇。你刚才在这个播客中简短地提到了斯坦利·鲍德温。斯坦利·鲍德温非常像个霍比特人。他喜欢穿马甲，他是这里的人，来自伍斯特郡。他绝对是一种新类型的政治家，我不浪漫，我想，不迷人。他有一句名言，你知道的，轰炸机总是能突破防线，就像担心轰炸一样，你知道的，新战争将是末日般的存在以及诸如此类的事情。我认为比尔博完全体现了这种张力。你知道的，他内心有一部分被冒险和刺激所吸引。但与此同时，他又感到焦虑，
about reclaiming something that was lost, whereas Frodo in the Lord of the Rings has to go out and save the world. And Lord of the Rings was probably written at a time when, you know, the threat of the Nazis was unavoidable. The wolf was at the door. Yeah, it's much less existential in the Hobbit. It's actually the love of exploration and adventure. And I guess to some extent, the story of the Hobbit, it's all about Bilbo finding his courage, really, not physical courage, because he never really fights in battles and does all those things. In fact, there's a lovely moment, actually, the critic Tom Shippey mentions it, and I thought, gosh, this is so true. The bravest thing that Bilbo ever does is much later on, he's on his own, he's in a tunnel, and he's going to see
恋家，恐惧。我认为他是托尔金写作时那一代许多人精神面貌的完美化身。但我也觉得有趣的是，《指环王》显然写得稍晚一些。所以当这些内容被创作时，战争的暴风雨乌云有点像，它们在地平线上，但还没有在头顶聚集。比尔博并没有被迫离开他在霍比特洞里的舒适生活，因为他知道他必须做点什么来拯救他的家园。他去不是因为他知道门外有黑暗，他可以在平息和消灭黑暗中发挥作用。在《霍比特人》中，赌注没那么高。门口还没有生存威胁。没有。这只关乎
Smauk. The dwarves have sent him. The dwarfs are so mean to Bilbo throughout. I was so struck by that. Yeah. And the Raider says, this was the bravest thing he ever did. The tremendous thing that happened afterwards were nothing. He fought the real battle in that tunnel alone before he ever saw the vast danger that lay in wait. And I thought, the man who's written those words is a man who stood in a trench with his mates. waiting for the whistle. They had no idea what was on the other side. But that dark night of the soul, that kind of moment when you know you're about to go into battle, but you don't know what's waiting. You have to go. You have to overcome it. Overcome yourself. Yeah. Totally. So that
夺回失去的东西，而《指环王》中的弗罗多则必须走出去拯救世界。而且《指环王》的创作时期可能纳粹的威胁是无法避免的。狼已经在门前了。是的，《霍比特人》中的生存危机感要小得多。实际上，它是关于对探索和冒险的热爱。我想在某种程度上，《霍比特人》的故事完全是关于比尔博找到自己的勇气，真正的勇气，而不是肉体上的勇气，因为他从未真正参与战斗并做那些事。事实上，有一个美妙的时刻，评论家汤姆·希佩提到了这一点，我想，天哪，这太真实了。比尔博做过的最勇敢的事情要晚得多，他独自一人，在一个隧道里，他要去见
to me is some of the modernity of the Hobbit. That it's written by somebody who doesn't think that war is all exciting and glamorous. Yeah. That's a really interesting thing that Tolkien does throughout. He situates you in an imaginary world in order to tell you something about the realities of our world. In other words, adventures are not heroic and exciting. They're often just really uncomfortable. There's a lot of sitting in the rain and there's a lot of not getting dinner. The goodies don't necessarily come out of winning better people. Winning often makes them worse people. Heroes don't instinctively run headfirst into battle. They have a sense of their mortality and fear as much as the rest of us. They do. Anyway, Bilbo is nevertheless dragged into the adventure by Gandalf. And Gandalf must be
史矛革。矮人们把他派去的。矮人们在整个过程中对比尔博太刻薄了。我对此印象深刻。是的。而旁白说，这是他做过的最勇敢的事。之后发生的那些惊天动地的事都不算什么。他在那个隧道里独自完成了真正的战斗，甚至在他看到潜伏的巨大危险之前。我想，写下这些字的人是一个曾在战壕里和战友们一起
one of the most iconic characters of any fantasy series ever. Oh, yeah. I mean, he is the original Dumbledore, right? He's a version of Merlin, though, don't you think? He's less dark, he's got a lot more humor to him, a lot more twinkle, he's more fallible. But yeah, I would say in the way that Merlin guides the quest, so does Gandalf. Yeah. He's like the dwarves manager. He is, and he's basically recruited Bilbo very much against his will to be a burglar for them. And actually, sometimes people, frankly, who I think don't know what they're talking about, say, oh, I don't think Tolkien's a very good writer, because actually they don't like the songs or whatever it might be. Actually, when you look at those first chapters, Tolkien's a great writer because he
等待冲锋哨声响起的人。他们根本不知道另一边是什么。但那种灵魂的至暗时刻，那种你知道自己即将上战场却不知道等待着你的是什么的那种时刻。你必须去。你必须克服它。克服你自己。完全如此。所以对我来说，这就是《霍比特人》的现代性所在。
completely captures the different characters and almost the different kind of temporal registers of the characters through the way they speak. So Bilbo is very modern. Bilbo speaks in a modern middle class way and he has coffee and he has pantries and all of this and he's likened at one point, his streak is likened to the whistle of a train coming through a tunnel. So we see in Bilbo, as you said, he's a bridge to this world. He's a modern figure. like us. And if you want to hear the full episode, you just need to sign up to the Restis History Club
它是由一个不认为战争充满刺激和迷人色彩的人写的。是的。这是托尔金自始至终所做的一个非常有趣的事情。他将你置于一个虚构的世界中，以便向你讲述一些关于我们现实世界的事情。换句话说，冒险并非英雄主义和激动人心。它们往往只是非常令人不舒服。有很多时间坐在雨里，有很多时间吃不上晚饭。好人并不一定会因为获胜而成为更好的人。获胜往往让他们变得更糟糕。英雄并不会本能地一头冲进战场。他们像我们其他人一样，对自己的凡人本质和恐惧有着清醒的认识。他们确实如此。无论如何，比尔博最终还是被甘道夫拉进了这场冒险。甘道夫一定
at the Restis History.com. And not only will you get access to this thrilling new show, but you get all the usual benefits, you get the ad-free listening, the early access to episodes, the bonus episodes. And if you're not a massive fan of The Hobbit, don't despair. Because in the next couple of weeks,
是任何奇幻系列中最具标志性的角色之一。哦，是的。我的意思是，他就是最初的邓布利多，对吧？但他也是梅林的某种版本，你不觉得吗？他没那么黑暗，他有更多的幽默感，更多眨眼的顽皮，他更容易犯错。但是是的，我觉得就像梅林指引着探索一样，甘道夫也是如此。是的。他就像是矮人们的经理人。他的确是，他基本上是非常违背比尔博意愿地招募了他作为他们的飞贼。事实上，有时人们，坦率地说，我认为他们根本不知道自己在说些什么，他们会说，哦，我觉得托尔金不是一个很好的作家，因为他们其实不喜欢那些歌或者别的什么。事实上，当你仔细看前几章时，托尔金是个伟大的作家，因为他
we'll be doing Bram Stoker's chilling Dracula. And we'll be doing Margaret Atwood's dystopian fable, The Handmaid's Tale. Bye-bye. Hey, it's Anthony Scaramucci from the racist politics, US. If you're looking for something to play next, Caddy Kay and I just launched a new mini-series about Ronald Reagan. We're digging into the real Reagan story, the rise, the drama, how his world has been turned upside down in the age of Trump.
通过他们说话的方式，完全捕捉到了不同角色的特质，甚至捕捉到了这些角色不同的时间语调。所以比尔博非常现代。比尔博以一种现代中产阶级的方式说话，他喝咖啡，他有食品储藏室诸如此类，在某个时刻他的性格被比作火车穿过隧道的呼啸声。所以我们在比尔博身上看到，正如你所说，他是通往这个世界的桥梁。他是一个现代人物，
We trace his rise from Hollywood to the White House, from his role in ending the Cold War to reviving the economy. And we also confront those scandals, Iran-Contra, his assassination attempt, and his failure around the AIDS epidemic. Just search the rest of politics, US, wherever you get your podcast. Here's a clip from the series. Ronald Reagan knew how to go big and go bold. He truly was the great communicator. Together, we're going to do what has to be done.
就像我们一样。如果你想听完整的节目，你只需要在therestofhistory.com注册加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部。不仅能收听这个惊心动魄的新节目，还能享受所有常规福利，比如无广告收听、提前收听节目以及奖励节目。如果你不是《霍比特人》的超级粉丝，也不必绝望。因为在接下来的几周里，
He regrounded the GOP and conservative principles. Free markets, small government, and an unshakable faith in American exceptionalism. Mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall. Ronald Reagan shook the country. People keep looking to government for the answer, and government's the problem. President Reagan was shot in the chest by a gunman outside the Washington Hotel. We did not trade weapons or anything else for hostages. Uncomfortable as it is to admit, the 40th president inadvertently prepared the ground for the 45th.
我们将推出布拉姆·斯托克的令人毛骨悚然的《吸血鬼德古拉》。我们还将推出玛格丽特·阿特伍德的反乌托邦寓言《使女的故事》。再见。嘿，我是来自“政治的其余部分：美国”的安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。如果你正在寻找下一个要收听的节目，卡迪·凯和我刚刚推出了一部关于罗纳德·里根的新迷你剧。我们将深入挖掘里根的真实故事，他的崛起、戏剧性，以及他的世界在特朗普时代是如何天翻地覆的。
It's not Reagan's party anymore. Donald Trump destroyed Ronald Reagan. I thought he was great, his style, his attitude, but not great, entree. Will we be the party of conservatism? Or will we follow the siren song of populism? Only one man has the proven experience we need. Together, we'll make America great again. Thank you very much.
我们追踪他从好莱坞到白宫的崛起，从他在结束冷战中的角色到重振经济。我们还将直面那些丑闻，伊朗门事件、他的暗杀未遂事件，以及他在艾滋病流行期间的应对失败。只需在你获取播客的任何地方搜索“the rest of politics, US”。以下是该系列的一个片段。罗纳德·里根懂得如何做到宏大和大胆。他确实是伟大的沟通者。在一起，我们将完成必须完成的事。
We hope you enjoyed that clip to hear the full series just search the rest is politics, US. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他重新奠定了共和党和保守主义原则的基础。自由市场、小政府，以及对美国例外论不可动摇的信念。戈尔巴乔夫先生，推倒这堵墙。罗纳德·里根震撼了国家。人们不断向政府寻求答案，而政府就是问题所在。里根总统在华盛顿一家酒店外遭到枪手胸部枪击。我们没有为获取人质而交易武器或其他任何东西。尽管承认这一点很不舒服，但第四十任总统无意间为第四十五任总统铺平了道路。